nous allons donc passer à l'audition de
Madame la Défenseur des droits nous
avons le plaisir de recevoir Madame
cléredon afin qu'elle puisse nous
présenter son troisième rapport annuel
d'activité qui a été publié le 17 avril
dernier nous avions l'an dernier puis
vous entendre qu'au mois d'octobre en
raison du renouvellement de l'assemblée
et des travaux qui nous avait occupés au
cours de l'été mais nous renouons avec
le la tradition de vos auditionner
désormais au printemps votre autorité je
le rappelle a été créée à la suite de la
révision constitutionnelle de 2008 et
c'est vu attribuer plusieurs anciennes
les compétences pardon de plusieurs
anciennes autorités administratives
indépendantes avec un champ de
compétences désormais très larges les
relations entre les citoyens et
l'administration la lutte contre les
discriminations la protection des
enfants la déontologie de la sécurité et
enfin la protection et l'accompagnement
des lanceurs d'alerte ce qui est la
petite dernière dans vos attributions
c'est donc peu surprenant que votre
autorité fasse l'objet d'un très grand
nombre de saisines plus de 125 000 dans
votre rapport pour ce qui concerne
l'année 2022 avec un chiffre en
constance progression avant de vous
donner la parole pour nous donner les
grandes lignes de ce rapport je vous
précise que vous êtes accompagné alors
je ne sais pas si j'ai l'intégralité de
ce qui vous accompagne votre secrétaire
général à votre droite Madame Mireille
lecorps madame Pauline Caby on va
charger de la déontologie de la sécurité
et Madame Cécile Barrois de Saint-Rémy
chargé des lanceurs d'alerte alors je
crois qu'il me manque voilà il me manque
une de vos
Saint-Martin concert parlementaire
sur la question des lanceurs d'alerte
c'est un travail qui avait beaucoup
occupé la commission des lois notamment
notre ancien collègue Sylvain vaserman
je sais que dans ce domaine vous avez
également beaucoup de saisies et ce sera
une de mes premières questions sur la
camp et dans quel rapport vous envisagez
de présenter la doctrine et qui vous
incombe en la matière nous avons aussi
observé dans le rapport d'activités que
vous nous avez remis en tout cas que
vous m'avez remis la semaine passée en
main propre que plusieurs saisies n'ont
fortement progressé les relations avec
les services publics plus 14%, la
défense des droits de l'enfant plus 20%
et le nombre de saisines sont relatifs
discrimination en hausse sensible depuis
2021 qui s'est stabilisé l'an dernier
alors vous avez commis des travaux sur
la dématérialisation qui rejoignent les
travaux de notre commission sur les
limites de l'usage numérique dans
l'accès aux administration je renvoie
ici au rapport qui avait été commis sur
le budget administration territorial et
gestion de général pardon de l'État nous
avons également échangé sur les failles
de de ma qui à peine une réponse de
l'État sur les difficultés que nos
administes rencontres et des artisans
qui sont directement concernés et puis
nous avons aussi parlé des difficultés
c'est la dématérialisation et
principalement au regard du droit des
étrangers je crois que nous aurons un
projet de loi sur sur la question et qui
devra impérativement y répondre enfin
sur le droit des enfants nous avions
étudié et je vous l'avais mentionné une
proposition de loi sur il a peu
proposition là sur le droit à l'image
des enfants de Monsieur Studer qui fera
l'objet d'une commission mixte paritaire
dans les prochaines semaines et j'avais
évoqué avec vous et je pense que on peut
en discuter également les difficultés de
coordination entre les services de
l'État et des départements notamment sur
la nécessité ou l'opportunité de
recentraliser certaines compétences des
départements en la matière pour faire
face aux iniquités territoriales graves
que vous avez recensé dernière question
que je voudrais vous poser avant de
passer la parole à mes collègues comment
expliquer vous après la diminution
presque d'un tiers du nombre de
décisions rendus alors que les saisies
n'ont cessé d'augmenter je pense qu'on
en a discuté mais c'est un bon
d'instruire nos collègues répondre à la
question le fait que vous ayez réalisé
aussi un exercice nouveau consistant
effectuer une droite visite à droite de
visite dans les Antilles moi j'aurais
que vous puissiez nous dire quel est le
bilan que vous réalisez de ce travail
c'est deux semaines que vous avez passé
aux Antilles est-ce que ce travail vous
a permis de constater une amélioration
plus rapide des situations observées
est-ce que vous souhaitez le renouveler
dans quel territoire où est-ce que vous
avez des priorités à titre et puis enfin
vous avez reçu des saisies dans le cadre
des différentes manifestations je
voudrais que vous puissiez nous
instruire parce qu'on sait que c'est
manifestations des lieux à des violences
graves parfois des forces de l'ordre
également de la part des manifestants et
donc j'aimerais savoir là encore quel
bilan vous en vous en tirez vous avez la
parole pour faire un propos introductif
nos collègues vous interrogeront pour
une durée de 2 minutes chacun je
prendrai une dizaine de questions et
puis après vous répondrez par tranche de
10 questions la défenseur droit vous
avez la parole bienvenue à la commission
des lois monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés d'abord je
tiens à vous remercier de m'accueillir
aujourd'hui c'est un moment important
pour moi de vous partager merci monsieur
le Président d'en avoir dit déjà
quelques premiers éléments de vous
partager notre rapport annuel parce que
d'abord c'est vraiment inscrit dans la
loi le fait de vous le présenter comme
le présenter d'ailleurs au Sénat et un
rendez-vous est prévu et au président de
la République un rendez-vous sera aussi
prévu d'ici l'été c'est pour moi un
moment important qui me permet de vous
dire un peu l'état des lieux de
l'institution mais surtout et je
voudrais insister sur ce point c'est que
c'est un révélateur d'atteinte aux
droits d'une partie de la population des
difficultés qui sont vécues par de
nombreuses personnes et vous m'avez
souvent entendu dire que nous sommes
là-dessus un observatoire qui est
intéressant à la fois pour les pouvoirs
publics et pour le et pour le et pour le
Parlement je redis que nous sommes une
autorité administrative indépendante
inscrite dans la Constitution avec deux
missions la première c'est vraiment de
traiter les réclamations que nous
recevons dans les cinq domaines de
compétence que vous avez bien bien
rappelé et donc de rétablir les
personnes dans les dans leurs droits à
partir de ces réclamations et la
deuxième mission qui est très claire
dans la loi c'est de Prom voir les
droits et les libertés ça veut vraiment
dire que le législateur dès le début a
bien penser que il s'agissait pas
simplement de réparer individuellement
mais bien de faire un certain nombre de
préconisations de rendre des avis sur
des projets propositions loi de faire
des rapports sur ce que nous observons
parce que l'idée c'est évidemment de
diminuer les problèmes ces missions à
voulait vous les avez rappelé protection
des droits des enfants protection
orientation des lanceurs d'alerte nous
sommes l'organe de contrôle externe de
la déontologie des forces de sécurité
nous sommes aussi chargés de la lutte
contre les discriminations et je cite en
dernier d'ailleurs celui que vous avez
cité en premier c'est la défense des
droits des usagers de service public et
j'y reviendrai qui est vraiment 80% des
réclamations alors évidemment ces
missions on peut avoir l'impression
qu'elles sont diverses mais réellement
elles se complètent elles ont un point
commun c'est la défense des droits et
des libertés et d'ailleurs je dirais que
c'est le point de départ et
l'aboutissement de chaque mission les
droits et les libertés sont à la fois la
boussole qui nous guident dans notre
activité et dans un contexte d'ailleurs
qui sont en danger leur préservation est
aussi notre notre raison d'être et pour
mener à bien nos missions le législateur
nous a donné des pouvoirs de médiation
des pouvoirs d'enquête des pouvoirs de
recommandation et vous dire d'ailleurs
que
80% des réclamations que nous traitons
sont traités en médiation qui
aboutissent dans les trois quarts des
cas ils reviendrai vous redire qu'on
s'appuie pour ça sur 250 agents qui sont
majoritairement au siège et avec
quelques chefs de pôle régionaux et puis
dépôt de régionaux avec 570 délégués
territoriaux qui sont des qui sont des
bénévoles qui ont une indemnité qui
reçoivent les réclamants en présentiel
120 jeunes ambassadeurs et ambassadrices
des droits qui sont des services
civiques et qui vont dans les écoles et
les collèges lycées et autres lieux
parlaient des parler des droits de
l'enfant et de la lutte contre les
discriminations vous l'avez rappelé on
était après de 126 000 réclamations pour
l'année 2022 une augmentation de 10% si
je fais le récapitulatif en
2020 quand l'année où je suis arrivé on
en était à 100 réclamation 115 000 en
2021 et 100 et 126000 en 2022
l'actualité évidemment m'a fait préciser
notre rôle sur le contrôle externe des
forces de sécurité j'y reviendrai mais
si vous le voulez bien je voudrais
vraiment commencer par les droits
d'usagers de service public est-ce que
nous observons j'en viendrai ensuite à
la question des droits des enfants puis
à la déontologie et des forces de
sécurité la lutte contre les
discriminations et enfin on finira avec
les avec les lanceurs d'alerte sur la
question de d'abord des services publics
ce que j'observe c'est un éloignement
des services publics les services
publics incarnent l'accès aux droits et
ils ont d'ailleurs pour mission de les
rendre concret et accessibles et ce que
nous constatons de manière persistante
c'est la déshumanisation des services
publics elle se traduit par une
dégradation des relations avec les
usagers le silence l'absence de réponse
des administrations qui entraînent la
résignation le non recours la perte de
droit pour les usagers et je précise
toujours quand je dis cela que je ne
nullement cause des agents publics mais
bien au contraire le manque d'agent
public leur effacement d'ailleurs du
fait d'une dématérialisation excessive
où on avançait qu'on pouvait réduire
fortement les effectifs avec la
dématérialisation la relation avec les
services publics c'est vraiment notre
quotidien d'abord à tous et les
difficultés dans cette relation peuvent
tous nous concerner pas simplement ceux
qui sont le plus éloignés du droit que
ce soit avec l'école la CAF les impôts
l'assurance maladie Pôle Emploi sa
commune nous pouvons nous trouver à
différents moments de notre vie dans une
situation en fait d'incompréhension avec
l'administration mais les conséquences
elles sont redoutables en particulier
pour les personnes les plus vulnérables
lorsqu'elles se traduisent notamment par
des ruptures de droits sociaux nous
constatons que ces difficultés sont
renforcées par la dématérialisation qui
est l'une des expressions d'ailleurs du
recul des services publics les droits ne
peuvent être garantis en fait que si il
y a des personnes pour y répondre et
pour y répondre aussi pour répondre aux
situations particulières
la dématérialisation je le répète la
dématérialisation est une chance pour
plein de personnes et pour plein de
démarches mais ça ne peut pas être la
seule possibilité et c'est une politique
publique qui est menée sans avoir été
évalué dans sa globalité donc le coup
d'ailleurs et l'efficacité non pas été
mesuré nous avons vous le savez vous
l'avez dit beaucoup travailler sur ce
sujet nous avons précisément décrit les
atteintes au droit qui découlent de
cette dématérialisation des services
publics nous avons rendu deux rapports
vous avez évoqué il y avait le premier
en 2019 le second en 2022 puisqu'on fait
un suivi de nos recommandations puis
parce qu'on a observé aussi une
aggravation de de la situation je pense
qu'ils ont contribué à la prise de
conscience des enjeux liés à la
transformation de nos services publics
et parce que cette dématérialisation
elle se fait au prix pour certaines
personnes de fait d'une exclusion je
voudrais vous rappeler là-dessus du
dernier chiffre du du creddock qui
évoque près de 16 millions de personnes
soit 31,5% des Français de plus de 18
ans vivant en métropole sont concernés
par ce phénomène d'éloignement des
services publics ça veut dire qu'on est
quand même prêt d'un tiers de la
population qui est éloignée des services
publics entre ceux qui sont en
difficulté avec le numérique ceux qui
n'ont pas forcément de connexion
internet oui ça existe encore le
creddock les évalues à 4 millions de
personnes donc ce n'est pas rien et je
redis la dématérialisation peut être une
chance elle peut simplifier des
démarches mais d'ailleurs chacun d'entre
nous peut se retrouver confronté un site
Internet des services publics qui bug
sur lequel on a on n'arrive pas à
résoudre le problème ce qui fera pendant
cette dématérialisation c'est qu'elle
s'accompagne d'un report sur l'usagé de
tâches qui d'abord et qui avant incombé
à l'administration on demande à l'usager
de s'adapter alors que le principe même
du service public c'est lui qui doit
s'adapter à l'usager on demande là
l'usager de s'équiper de se former
d'être capable de faire des démarches en
ligne tout en comprenant d'ailleurs le
langage administratif et en plus de ne
pas commettre d'erreurs et je trouve que
ça renvoie vraiment à la question du
quel service public voulons-nous et le
1er défi que doit relever cette
transformation numérique des services
public c'est de garantir leur
accessibilité dans le respect des
principes qu'il guide et en particulier
du principe d'égalité et aujourd'hui ce
que nous constatons c'est que les
alternatives au numérique sont très
insuffisantes et avec l'Institut
national de la consommation nous avions
justement mené une étude vous en avez
probablement entendu parler sur
l'évaluation des réponses apportées aux
usagers par les plateformes
téléphoniques qui justement peut être
une alternative au tout numérique de
quatre services publics et les résultats
sur les 1500 appels passés 40% n'ont pas
abouti et souvent on dit que les
personnes sont éloignées du droit et
nous avons plutôt le sentiment que le
service public s'est éloigné d'elle
notamment des plus vulnérables des plus
pauvres en faisant peser sur une charge
administrative une charge matérielle et
aussi mentale très lourde et la
dématérialisation ne peut être
considérée comme un progrès si elle
exclut et si elle déshumanise le service
public
alors que 28% de la population éprouve
des difficultés face aux démarches
administratives je redis que c'est au
service de s'adapter à l'usager et non
l'inverse et je voudrais vous citer un
exemple je pense à une une femme âgée
vous avez justement évoqué la prime
rénoble qui devait changer sa chaudière
et pour cela elle pouvait bénéficier de
ma prime rénove elle faisait partie des
personnes accessibles donc créer un
compte sur le site de Lana à l'Agence
nationale de l'habitat et puis en fait
malgré plusieurs tentatives elle n'a pas
réussi à compléter le dossier simplement
en raison d'un dysfonctionnement du site
et entre-temps sa chaudière à cessé de
fonctionner elle s'est retrouvée en
plein hiver sans eau chaude sans
chauffage elle serait résolue du coup à
faire les travaux avant la réponse de
Lana et ce qui en principe comme
conséquence de la privée du bénéfice de
la prime de ma prime rénov et on est en
face du cas d'une femme âgée qui se
trouve privée du net financière auquel
elle a droit en raison en fait d'un
dysfonctionnement dans ces techniques de
de la plateforme dans une procédure je
le rappelle qui est entièrement
dématérialisée et qui est sans
alternative justement ce que nous avions
préconisé en l'occurrence l'intervention
de l'institution du défenseur des droits
a permis le versement de l'aide mais
évidemment nous ne sommes pas saisis de
toutes de toutes les difficultés nous
avons reçu des centaines de réclamations
similaires dès 2020 nous avons constaté
des écueils dans le traitement des
demandes des problèmes techniques chez
les dix des défauts d'information aussi
des délais de traitements et des
difficultés liées à la dématérialisation
totale toutes ces entraves vont
entraîner d'importantes conséquences
pour les usagers dont certains ont passé
l'hiver justement sans chauffage pour
respecter les droits les services
publics ne peuvent absolument pas être
intégralement des matérialisés et à
partir de ces situations de nos enquêtes
on adressait un certain nombre de
recommandations à Lana à l'Agence
nationale de l'habitat les au moment où
nous avons rendu cette décision nous
avions eu à peu près 500 saisies 900
depuis que nous avons rendu cette
décision c'est à dire depuis le mois
d'octobre et les réclamations se
poursuivent donc le problème n'est
absolument pas réglé et nos délégués
d'ailleurs sont totalement dépités de se
retrouver sans réponse quand il
saisissent la sur certaines difficultés
je vous rappelle et je vous le redirai
d'ailleurs ensuite que nos délégués sont
des bénévoles ils reçoivent une
indemnité je dirais qu'ils trouvent une
satisfaction parce qu'ils arrivent à
régler des problèmes mais s'ils n'ont
pas de réponse des administrations et
qu'ils n'arrivent pas à régler le
problème leur travail perd absolument
tout sens et nous en perdons certains
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de réponse des
des administrations et ces réclamations
soulignent que la que la que la
dématérialisation elle touche
particulièrement des personnes en
situation de vulnérabilité elle
contribue d'ailleurs aussi à créer des
vulnérabilités et je pense là notamment
aux personnes étrangères qui rencontrent
de nombreux obstacles à l'exercice de
leurs droits les réclamations relatives
au droit des étrangers sont devenus le
premier motif de ces signes de
l'institution on en est pratiquement à
un quart des réclamations 24% très
précisément pour 2022 pour les quatre
premiers mois de l'année sur les
chiffres que nous avons c'est 30% des
réclamations qui concernent les droits
des étrangers et vous l'entendez c'est
vraiment quelque chose sur lequel je
suis particulièrement
euh en colère parce que ce sont
majoritairement ces réclamations pour
des renouvellements de droits au séjour
des personnes qui défaitent
l'obtiendront et qui se retrouvent
finalement en situation irrégulière qui
n'arrivent pas à prendre de rendez-vous
en préfecture qui quand leur dossier est
déposé non pas de réponse multiplie les
les récipissés certaines perdent leur
emploi perdent leur logement perdent des
aides auxquelles ils ont droit on est
dans une situation qui est inacceptable
qui est insupportable parce que le
service public ne répond pas et ce que
nous constatons c'est une dégradation de
l'accueil des étrangers en France et
puis je dirais cette dématérialisation
puisque en fait les rendez-vous
justement en préfecture se prennent en
ligne et et c'est bien et c'est bien la
difficulté c'est qu'elle met hors de vue
finalement cette dégradation l'indemnité
a été invisibilisée en fait avant
envoyer des queues devant les
préfectures et quand même on était
choqué ce qu'on pouvait observer c'est
que on les voit pas maintenant elles
sont
virtuel elles sont devant les
ordinateurs pour essayer de décrocher à
un rendez-vous et le service public doit
conserver son rôle de soutien et de
services au public veillez à ne pas
engendrer par une action détournée de
ses objectifs finition de la précarité
et c'est vraiment notre rôle de le
rappeler
les conséquences de la dématérialisation
empêche l'accès de nombreux usagers au
service public et donc à leurs droits
ils sont graves individuellement pour
les personnes ils sont grave
collectivement avec une population qui
ne se voit plus incarnée et s'incarner
le principe d'égalité nous sommes ici
confrontés à un dysfonctionnement
structurel auquel mon institution avec
ses moyens ne peut pas pallier seul et
qui surtout n'en a pas la vocation nous
ne pouvons nous ne devons pas nous
substituer au service public notre rôle
il est de répondre réclamation
individuelle de révéler les atteintes
aux droits de faire des recommandations
pour que les pouvoirs publics s'en
saisissent sans réaction très
honnêtement dans ce domaine mon
institution risque l'embolie risque de
ne plus être en mesure de répondre aux
personnes qui s'adressent à elle est-il
normal qu'un usagé doivent saisir soit
le juge des référés du tribunal
administratif soit le Défenseur des
droits seulement pour obtenir un
rendez-vous franchement ce système
marche sur la tête et je n'ai pas
vocation à être le doctolib des
rendez-vous en préfecture et je reprends
là dessus l'expression de la présidente
du tribunal administratif de Versailles
le problème doit être résolu à la source
au niveau des préfectures et là je redis
aucune accusation contre les agents dans
ces préfectures qui cherchent à faire au
mieux mais la Cour des comptes l'a très
bien dit la réduction des effectifs de
façon trop importante empêche finalement
les agents de traiter l'ensemble des
dossiers avant d'aborder c'était donc le
premier point sur la question de ces
difficultés d'accès aux services publics
que je trouve très impressionnant qui
mine notre coalition sociale et qui
porte des atteintes à notre à notre
démocratie avant d'aborder la question
des des droits des enfants je voudrais
vous dire et vous expliquer tout le
travail que nous faisons nous aussi pour
être accessible à tous parce que je veux
vraiment que notre institution puisse
être un recours pour tous et qu'elle
soit facilement accessible et nous
travaillons à réduire la distance avec
les personnes qui nous saisissent qui
sont susceptibles de le faire qui ne
nous connaissent pas d'ailleurs
forcément l'expression aller vers chez
nous à tous son sens
qui est largement utilisé et qui est
important nous sommes joignables
gratuitement
par mail par téléphone partout en France
avec nos 570 délégués qui assure des
permanences qui reçoivent physiquement
les réclamants qui sont présents dans
990 points d'accueil puisqu'ils font
deux demi-journées de permanence ils les
font pas toujours au même endroit nous
sommes présents dans des préfectures des
maisons de la justice et du droit nous
allons nous créons de nouvelles
permanences dans des locaux
d'association dans des centres sociaux
nous sommes présents dans une centaine
d'espaces françaises dans des tirs-le
dans des missions locales pour essayer
justement de toucher les jeunes et
d'être toujours plus accessible
dans leur permanence nos délégués
Comblain manque dont souffre de plus en
plus nos services publics la présence de
guichet qui permette un accueil physique
une écoute grâce à leur implication à
leur rigueur l'action de nos délégués et
de nos agents est efficaces 75% de nos
médiations ont abouti en 2022 nous
faisons aussi en sorte d'être joignable
par téléphone 8000 appels mensuels sur
notre plateforme téléphonique
généraliste avec un taux de décroché de
plus de 90% pour répondre à des demandes
d'information d'explications nous avons
aussi mis en place un numéro dédié et
gratuit pour les détenus le 31 41 qui
risque d'ailleurs d'être victime un peu
de son succès puisque les du coup les
détenus l'utilisent largement et par
ailleurs vous le savez le site anti
discrimination avec le numéro de
téléphone 39-28 que nous avons créé à la
demande du Président de la République
qui est un peu plus de 200 qui est un
service d'accompagnement gratuit qui
recense aussi un millier d'acteurs
engagés localement
lutte contre les discriminations ne
doivent pas reposer uniquement contre
les personnes qui en sont victimes et en
proposant une écoute attentive avec des
écoutants qui prennent le temps certains
appels peuvent durer plus de plus de 45
minutes nous montrons aux personnes
qu'elles ont la possibilité de faire
valoir et faire respecter leurs droits
et
l'occasion de la présentation de ce
rapport c'est de c'est de redire que
l'institution du Défenseur des droits
est un recours pour tous et peut
résoudre un certain nombre de de
situations je voudrais en venir
maintenant à la nécessaire défense des
droits des enfants nous constatons tout
d'abord que les enfants ne sont pas
considérés comme sujet de droit pas
suffisamment considéré comme sujet de
droit et nous intervenons pour des
enfants qui n'ont pas accès au logement
à l'éducation à la cantine à la
protection à laquelle ils ont droit je
voudrais commencer par vous parler de la
scolarisation des enfants en situation
de handicap qui reste très insuffisante
malgré les progrès et je ne nie pas les
progrès qu'il y a eu ces dernières
années mais paradoxalement nous avons
aussi de plus en plus de réclamation
dans ce domaine alors au-delà de
l'augmentation du nombre
d'accompagnements d'élèves en situation
de handicap les aesh les pouvoirs
publics doivent pouvoir rendre possible
la formation des enseignants pour mieux
garantir l'effectivité des droits de
l'enfant et au lieu de s'adapter à
l'enfant le système scolaire de fait
demande en fait à l'enfant et aussi à sa
famille de s'adapter au contrats nous
voyons encore des enfants qui sont
privés de liberté en centre de rétention
administrative parfois rattaché
arbitrairement à un tiers pour être
retenu je pense notamment à Mayotte je
m'attarde d'ailleurs quelques instants
sur Mayotte où les atteintes au droit
sont particulièrement fréquentes et
graves dans tous les domaines à cet
égard les actions liées à l'opération
dites ou embushu m'inquiète
particulièrement nous y attachons la
plus grande vigilance j'ai saisi
d'ailleurs à ce sujet le ministre de
l'Intérieur et d'autres ministres
concernés par des risques d'atteinte aux
Droits j'ai souhaité qu'une délégation
de juriste de l'institution se rendre
sur place
notre préoccupation porte sur deux
points le premier c'est sur les
conditions de des casages alors même que
le nombre de constructions est très
insuffisante pour que les familles
soient accueillies et d'autre part les
conditions d'éloignement des personnes
étrangères notamment en termes de droit
au recours de Réda de rétention en Kra
et et en LR1 les lieux de rétention
administrative qui ont été créés à cet
effet enfin à cet égard je rappelle que
la France vient d'être condamnée une
nouvelle fois par la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme pour la rétention
d'enfants ankra le projet de loi
immigration dont l'examen devant votre
assemblée reporté comporter une
disposition pour y mettre fin avec
toutefois des insuffisances que j'ai
souligné et que j'ai relevées dans la
vie que j'ai rendu sur ce projet de loi
lors de son examen par le Sénat les LRA
les lieux de rétention administrative ne
sont pas concernés les enfants de 16 à
18 ans ne sont pas concernés et aussi le
report de la date d'application nous ne
nous inquiéter parce qu'en réalité
franchement nul les besoins de loi bien
que cette Inter une question textuelle
soit utile pour changer déjà la pratique
or en tout cas Mayotte la pratique
perdure s'agissant aussi des droits de
l'enfant nous constatons que les enfants
qui doivent être protégés ne le sont pas
suffisamment et je pense
particulièrement à l'état de la
protection de l'enfance qui ne parvient
plus aujourd'hui à jouer son rôle des
juridictions dont les décisions ne sont
pas exécutées un manque de place en
foyer et d'assistant familiaux des
mesures éducatives en milieu ouvert
prise en charge dans des délais pouvant
excéder les six mois des ruptures dans
les parcours des enfants des changements
de famille d'accueil sans aucune
préparation de l'enfant ni de
considération pour le lien d'attachement
qui s'est construit entre l'enfant et la
famille d'accueil et telles sont
vraiment les situations que nous
constatons et qui portent atteinte au
droit de l'enfant et qui nous préoccupe
particulièrement là nous sommes encore
face à des problèmes systémiques nous
publions des recommandations qui
nécessitent des réponses des pouvoirs
publics à la hauteur de l'enjeu la
protection des enfants et le respect de
leurs droits j'en viens à la déontologie
des forces de sécurité et au nécessaire
respect des droits par les forces de
sécurité le législateur vous le savez a
fait du Défenseur des droits le
contrôleur indépendant des policiers des
gendarmes des surveillants
pénitentiaires des agents de sécurité
privée bref de toute personne qui exerce
une activité de sécurité vous savez que
la situation des derniers mois m'a
conduite à réexpliquer le rôle de
l'institution en tant que contrôle
indépendant d’adéontologie des forces de
sécurité cette fonction est absolument
essentielle dans une démocratie dans un
état de droit d'avoir un contrôle
indépendant il faut expliquer sans cesse
que c'est l'état dans lequel les
pouvoirs publics sont soumis d'ailleurs
au droit quand on parle de l'État de
droit la première exigence déontologique
et le respect du droit le respect de la
loi par les policiers et les gendarmes
ils sont au service de la loi des
institutions de la population nous avons
notamment rendu en 2022 deux décisions
pour des faits qui mettent directement
en cause ces principes et je pense à la
destruction en dehors de tout quatre les
le cadre légal de logement de famille
vivant dans des baraquements par des
bulldozers ou même par le feu par des
policiers les conséquences sont lourdes
les personnes se voient privées de leur
logement mais c'était un logement
précaire de leurs effets personnels de
tous les accompagnements que prévoient
la loi en matière de santé entre autres
de scolarisation des enfants grâce à la
rigueur de nos enquêtes à notre
indépendance nous pouvons faire la
lumière sur des faits sur les
responsabilités qui sont attachées
depuis plus de 20 ans le défenseur des
droits et la Commission nationale de
déontologie de la sécurité avant lui en
quête sur le comportement des policiers
et des gendarmes le législateur a pensé
que pour établir la confiance entre les
acteurs de la sécurité et les citoyens
il faut un contrôle indépendant et
transparent il a considéré que le
respect de la déontologie est protecteur
pour les policiers et les gendarmes
particulièrement nécessaires au regard
des responsabilités et aussi des
prérogatives qu'il détiennent ainsi nous
avons publié de nombreuses décisions sur
des comportements de policiers et de
gendarmes ainsi que sur un rôle le rôle
de leur hiérarchie et des avis sur le
maintien de l'ordre parce que la
particularité aussi justement de nos
enquêtes c'est que nous nous intéressons
pas simplement au fait commis par les
forces de l'ordre mais quelle a été
aussi leur formation et leur en est leur
encadrement à ce moment-là nous avons
constaté parfois des épisodes de
manifestations des dernières années des
privations de liberté arbitraire des
dissimulations du visage de policiers
qui sont contraires à la loi nous avons
rendu plusieurs décisions sur l'usage de
la force des armes dites de force
intermédiaires comme le LBD nous avons
publié un rapport intitulé le maintien
de l'ordre au regard des règles de
déontologique avaient été remis au
Président de l'Assemblée nationale en
2018 depuis nous avons pris position sur
le schéma de maintien de l'ordre et sur
plusieurs projets de loi comme la loi de
sécurité globale et c'est fort de cette
expertise et des pouvoirs que nous donne
la Constitution et la loi organique que
nous traitons les réclamations que nous
avons reçues
si je prends les dernières
manifestations depuis le mois de janvier
nous en sommes à 166 réclamations à ce
jour sur le comportement de policiers et
de gendarmes lors de manifestations et
les témoignages et images qui nous
parviennent laisse penser que les droits
ont été bafoués ma crainte et que la
répétition de tels actes contribue à les
rendre habituelles à rendre habituel
l'inacceptable qu'il risque d'installer
une logique de face à face dans la durée
pouvant entraîner des atteintes à la
liberté de manifester à l'intégrité
physique à la vie et je le rappelle la
sécurité des manifestants des policiers
et des gendarmes et la garantie de la
liberté de manifester sont de la
responsabilité de l'État et le respect
sans faille de la déontologie et la
condition dans la durée de la légitimité
des interventions des forces de sécurité
et nous contribuons justement par notre
travail à conforter cette légitimité en
veillant sur le respect de la
déontologie nous mènerons des enquêtes
impartiales contradictoire pour ses
faits en prenant le temps nécessaire et
j'ai bien conscience qu'il y a là un
décalage entre le temps médiatique et le
temps permettant de publier des
décisions résultat d'enquête abouties et
d'enquêtes en contradictoires et si ces
questions prennent une telle place dans
le débat politique et médiatique c'est
que notre société tout entière s'en
trouva abîmée ébranlé dans ses repères
et dans la confiance en ses institutions
et par notre action je suis convaincu
que nous contribuions à préserver les
repères indispensables ceux de la loi
des droits et des libertés et à cet
égard je rappelle combien le respect de
la liberté de manifester et de la
liberté d'associations doivent être
préservées je m'inquiète à cet égard
d'un climat qui contribue à fragiliser
l'édifice démocratique le contrôle
indépendant est toujours plus nécessaire
même s'il fait l'objet d'attaque et nous
participons au débat démocratique en
rendant public nos décisions notre
rapport annuel la défense des droits et
des libertés je voudrais en venir
maintenant passer également par la lutte
contre les discriminations
le deuxième volet de l'enquête Théo un
trajectoire origine qui a été réalisée
par l'Inde et par l'INSEE avec le
soutien de l'institution du Défenseur
des droits montre l'ampleur
descriminations et montre aussi que ces
discriminations sont en augmentation 19%
des personnes de 18 à 49 ans ont déclaré
souvent ou parfois des discriminations
au cours des cinq dernières années elles
étaient 14 en 2008 on est donc passé de
14% à 19%. l'enquête permet d'affirmer
que la discrimination est présente et
très présente dans notre pays qu'elle ne
régresse pas elle témoignent également
d'un manque d'intervention des pouvoirs
publics dans la lutte contre les
discriminations nous réalisons et vous
le savez aussi chaque année je vous en
avais parlé l'an dernier un baromètre
des discriminations avec l'oité
l'Organisation internationale du Travail
l'édition 2022 avait été consacrée aux
personnes employées par le secteur des
services à la personne qui révèle les
discriminations qu'elle subissent
sans ce type d'études une bonne part des
discriminations se réinvisible car en
fait les recours juridiques sont trop
rares sont très rares au Défenseur des
droits on a reçu seulement 6500
réclamations pour des faits de
discrimination c'est trop peu et nos
saisies ne sont manifestement que la
partie émergée de l'iceberg l'ampleur
des discriminations ne se reflète pas
dans les démarches qui sont effectuées
soit devant notre institution soit
devant la justice il y a une forme à la
fois de fatalisme mais aussi surtout on
le sait on le voit dans les réclamations
une crainte des représailles nous
agissons par voie d'enquête de médiation
aussi pour lutter contre les les
discriminations pour les situations que
nous recevons et c'est le cas là tout
récemment je voulais vous faire part de
cette réclamation que nous avons eu et
que nous avons réglé le cas d'un
professeur de guitare donc d'un homme
qu'une commune a à refusé d'embaucher
car il allait devenir père et qu'il
allait prendre son congé paternité de 28
jours et nous avons constaté la
discrimination voilà la discrimination
maintenant touche les touches les paires
et on a obtenu d'ailleurs qu'il soit
indemniser et je rappelle là dessus
vraiment que le que le Défenseur des
droits est un est un recours en la
matière je vous rappelle le site
indiscrit anti discrimination.fr le 39
et le téléphone le 39 28 nous devons
toujours rappeler que l'égalité est un
principe fondamental la discrimination
est une infraction il est urgence à
faire de la lutte contre les
discriminations une priorité publique il
faut combattre les discriminations car
elles sont une souffrance pour les
personnes elles sont une injustice elles
entravent leur parcours de vie leur
possibilité de se réaliser en tant
qu'individu elles ont des impacts sur la
santé physique et psychique toutes les
études le montrent je vais terminer avec
le
la compétence qui nous a été confiée en
2016 renforcé en 2022 vous l'avez
signalé monsieur le Président
sur la protection et l'orientation des
lanceurs des lanceurs d'alerte donc je
vous l'ai dit depuis 2016 il y a eu une
première loi de protection sur les
lanceurs d'alerte notre rôle a été
renforcée en 2022 cette loi nous a
conféré de nouveaux pouvoirs et surtout
un nouveau pouvoir celui de délivrer une
certification qui reconnaît la qualité
de lanceur d'alerte et puis nous a
justement adjoint une adjointe
supplémentaire Cécile Barotte Sarini qui
est qui est qui est derrière nous
recevons actuellement une saisie une par
jour dans ce domaine en 2022 c'était 134
donc là nous allons plus que doubler les
le nombre de réclamations et évidemment
cette question là est toujours une
inquiétude pour nous sur la capacité
d'une institution comme la nôtre à
pouvoir traiter l'ensemble de ces
réclamations avec une augmentation assez
vertigineuse évidemment tous ne seront
pas lanceur d'alerte mais de fait il
faut étudier tous les dossiers pour bien
vérifier s'ils sont ou non lanceur
d'alerte permettez-moi de terminer
par un mot d'alerte sur notre
organisation et nos moyens d'action
depuis plusieurs années les champs
d'action du défenseur du Défenseur des
droits n'ont cessé de s'élargir avec
l'adoption de texte législatif et
réglementaire qui lui confie de
nouvelles missions j'ai parlé des
lanceurs d'alerte mais aussi le
dispositif anti discrimination le suivi
de convention internationale ou encore
les expérimentations de médiation
préalable obligatoire dans ce cadre
l'activité accrue continuellement et se
traduit par une hausse des réclamations
de pullu de 70% depuis 2014 en 2022 je
l'ai dit c'était près de 126 000
réclamations ce qui représente une
augmentation de 29% par rapport à 2020
les appels reçus sur la plateforme
téléphonique historique témoigne aussi
de cette augmentation on est après de
100 000 appels sur la plateforme en 2022
dans le même temps entre 2014 et 2022 le
plafond d'emploi de l'institution a
augmenté de seulement
13%, c'est largement insuffisant pour
remplir nos missions nous sommes
clairement face à un risque très
prégnant de dégradation de niveau de
service rendu au réclamant de
difficultés voire d'impossibilité à Sat
ni même soutenir les personnes les plus
éloignées de leurs droits j'ai alerté la
première ministre de cette situation je
voulais aussi profiter de nos échanges
ce matin pour vous alerter également
j'ai tout à fait conscience du contexte
actuel des finances publiques nous avons
transmis des demandes très réalistes
d'abord je constate chaque jour combien
nos moyens sont très inférieurs à nos
homologues européens si je prends qu'un
exemple sur l'étude pollen Camille en
exergue la corrélation entre
l'indépendance qui était inversement
proportionnelle aux effectifs pour les
organismes externes de contrôle de la
déontologie des des services de sécurité
et et en fait la découverte de cette
étude on savait qu'on avait des
différences de moyens c'est surtout que
nous sommes en queue de liste en termes
de moyens dans les pays européens
c'est-à-dire en gros nous sommes les
plus pauvres pour traiter ce genre de
questions et quand nous faisons la
comparaison sur par exemple notre
travail de médiateur avec les embousmane
comparé la population nous sommes aussi
sur des moyens nettement nettement plus
faibles et ces moyens sont nécessaires
pour que l'institution
puisse jouer son rôle rétablir les
personnes dans leur droit nous sommes un
élément pacificateur au service de la
cohésion sociale dans notre pays et je
tiens à assister là-dessus la
Constitution nous a chargé de veiller au
respect des droits et des libertés
j'observe que les droits et les libertés
ceux qui les défendent sont
régulièrement attaqués ce rapport annuel
d'activité rappelle que les droits et
les libertés ne peuvent être mis au
second plan ils sont le fondement de
notre société de notre organisme de
notre organisation sociale ils sont
placés en préambule de notre
Constitution ils sont essentiels à la
démocratie et à l'étape droit et à
travers les situations individuelles que
nous recevons nous contribuons à
rétablir les personnes dans leur droit
mais aussi à renseigner les pouvoirs
publics l'ensemble des citoyens sur les
réponses plus globales à apporter pour
faire progresser le respect des droits
le rapport d'ailleurs montre
l'efficacité notre action en particulier
des médiations dans de nombreux domaines
montrent aussi l'implication sans
relâche des agents des délégués
territoriaux du Défenseur des droits
pour obtenir des avancées pour les
droits de tous et toutes pour rappeler
sans cesse où se situe l'inacceptable
comment remédier concrètement aux
atteintes aux droits mais nous ne
pouvons pas faire face seul nous ne
pouvons pas nous substituer aux
administrations au pouvoir public la
révélation d'atteinte structurelle aux
droits doit être prise en compte le
rapport d'en avoir la réalité des
épreuves que traverse celles et ceux qui
ne parviennent pas à faire respecter
leurs droits
prendre en compte cette réalité et non
seulement une exigence démocratique mais
aussi la seule voie pour rétablir la
confiance dans nos services publics et
dans nos institutions je vous remercie
je suis prête à répondre à vos questions
merci donc les questions pour une durée
de 2 minutes vous le savez madame Émilie
Chandler
monsieur le Président Madame la
Défenseur des droits mesdames et
messieurs les députés je tiens à vous
remercier de prendre le temps de
répondre aujourd'hui à notre commission
je vais aussi saluer le travail que vous
accomplissez en faveur de nos
concitoyens pour l'accès à leurs droits
et j'ai lu avec attention votre rapport
annuel il y a plusieurs éléments qui ont
attiré mon attention premièrement sur le
chant de la protection de l'enfance qui
a été déclaré par le Président de la
République un des grands enjeux de ce
quinquennat tout comme il a fait de la
lutte contre les violences conjugales la
grande cause de deux quinquennats le
Défenseur des droits est de plus en plus
sollicité notamment pour des
réclamations qui concernent pour 21%
d'entre elles la protection de l'enfance
et des enfants le nombre de saisines à
lui progresser de 20% entre 21 et 22 au
regard de ces éléments auriez-vous des
éléments sur le nombre de saisines dans
un cadre de violence intrafamiliales en
effet il semble essentiel dans des
affaires comme celle-ci de pouvoir
objectiver des saisines qui pourraient
être utilisées de manière abusive par
les agresseurs c'est en effet un
phénomène que nous avons constaté au
cours de la mission de la première
ministre qui appelle une grande
vigilance dans un deuxième temps une
interrogation sur les discriminations à
l'égard des femmes l'emploi privé la
fonction publique ont selon votre
rapport de grandes réticence liées au
sexe de même que la grossesse qui
représente des barrières importantes ces
deux grands ensembles représentent 7%
des saisines que vous avez enregistrées
et depuis plusieurs années nous avons
lancé plusieurs dispositifs avec
notamment la transposition de l'accord
du 30 novembre 2018 pour la fonction
publique et l'instauration dans la loi
pacte d'un quota 30% de femmes cadres
dirigeantes comme l'ont voulu le
gouvernement à la majorité
présidentielle pour s'assurer de
l'égalité en matière d'emploi en
percevez-vous cependant les limites si
oui comment pourrions vous pour comment
pourrions-nous améliorer les choses ces
éléments nous seront précieux dans le
cas de l'examen de la proposition de loi
sur la féminisation de la fonction
publique que notre Commission examinera
prochainement enfin une ultime question
concernant les médiations menées par
votre autorité vous indiquez que
celle-ci trouve une issue positive dans
plus de 75% des cas selon votre rapport
qu'en est-il des 25% restants comment
sont-elles traitées et quelles aides
reçoivent les usagers de la part de vos
services je vous remercie merci
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Défenseur des droits dans votre
rapport d'activité 2022 vous avez
consacré un paragraphe à l'observation
du respect des obligations
déontologiques par les forces de
sécurité y compris pénitentiaires vous y
faites un focus sur un signalement
émanant de l'Observatoire international
des prisons dont on ne peut nier les
tendances anti-carcérales notamment
quand ceci préconise d'avoir recours aux
alternatives aux peines plutôt qu'à la
construction de nouvelles places de
prison ainsi il apparaît que vous avez
accordé beaucoup d'énergie et de moyens
aux commentaires d'un tract syndical si
l'on ne peut contester le caractère
virulent de ce tract on ne peut pas ne
pas comprendre qu'il tentait d'illustrer
l'exaspération grandissante des agents
pénitentiaires ce ras-le-bol est
constitué et consécutif à la dégradation
de leurs conditions de travail qui elle
semble vous laisser indifférente en
effet il vous aura peut-être échappé que
selon la mutuelle des métiers de la
Justice et de la Sécurité 8 agents sur
10 souffrent d'un état de stress
permanent et autant estime que leur
travail à un impact négatif sur leur
santé dans cette ligne lors de mes
différentes visites dans des centres
pénitentiaires les agents m'ont exprimé
l'usure mental et physique qui les
rongeait ainsi on ne vous interrogeant
pas sur les causes de l'emploi d'un tel
langage vous contribue à nourrir le
terreau d'une haine et d'une
stigmatisation à l'encontre de certains
agents de service public que sont les
forces de l'ordre et les agents
pénitentiaires de plus nous sommes
particulièrement surpris de vous
entendre tenir des propos dignes de
l'extrême gauche lorsque vous dites que
notre population ne retrouvera confiance
en sapolis que si les dérapages font
l'objet de sanctions comme si les forces
de l'ordre étaient par essence violentes
cela est très déstabilisant de la part
d'une autorité administrative présentée
comme indépendante madame la Défenseur
des droits nous au rassemblement
national comme la grande majorité des
Français qui se sont exprimés dans un
sondage sévi-pof nous faisons confiance
à notre police et aux forces de l'ordre
général ainsi ma question est la
suivante allez-vous arrêter de donner
l'impression que vous instrumentalisez
vos fonctions rémunérer 15000 euros par
mois à des fins militantes et vous
consacrer pleinement au vrai problème
rencontrés par beaucoup de Français
Monsieur Jean-François Coulomme
combien constitutions
c'est pas nous madame monsieur le
Président Madame la Défenseur des droits
tout d'abord merci pour votre rapport
qui nous inspirera dans nos batailles en
hémicycle devant le constat accablant
implacable de votre mission sur le recul
et les atteintes au droit dans notre
pays nous espérons que le ministre de
l'Intérieur n'aura pas le mauvais goût
de vouloir vous dissoudre comme le
souhaite également l'extrême droite le 9
mai la Ligue des droits de l'homme le
Syndicat des Avocats de France et
l'association de défense des libertés
constitutionnelles déposées en référé un
recours devant le tribunal administratif
de Lille afin de mettre un terme au
fichier clandestin de certains parquets
ayant pour objet de collecter des
données sur les manifestants placés en
garde à vue comme la révélé le journal
Mediapart
ces fichiers qui détaillent les noms
prénoms date de naissance des personnes
placées en garde à vue lors des
manifestations ainsi que les suites
pénales à leur infligées ont été créés
dans certains parquets sans aucune base
légale depuis le début du mouvement
contre la réforme des retraites c'est
dans ce contexte de grande tension
méfiance et mise en alerte par de
nombreux observateurs sur ces débauches
d'arrestations arbitraire que certains
parquets ont décidé de créer des
fichiers sauvages malgré une loi du 6
janvier 78 qui interdit le traitement de
données révélant les opinions politiques
les convictions religieuses
philosophiques ou l'appartenance
syndicale d'une personne il s'agit ici
d'une atteinte très grave et
disproportionnée aux libertés
fondamentales et notamment au respect de
la vie privée de la liberté d'expression
et de manifester c'est la raison pour
laquelle le tribunal administratif de
Lille a été saisie d'un référé liberté
pour l'arrêt immédiat de l'utilisation
de ces fichiers leur destruction ou
placement sous séquestre ainsi que
l'envoi d'information à toutes les
personnes fichées à leur insu quant à
leur situation et au recours dont elles
dispose devant cet arbitraire il y a
deux jours le tribunal administratif de
Lille a donc jugé le caractère
effectivement
urgent de ces requêtes et nous serons
demain jeudi le sort qui sera réservé à
ses fichiers clandestins très inquiétant
en termes de liberté que suggérez-vous
madame la Défenseur des droits face à
ses dérives et comment inviter qu'elles
ne continue de gangrener notre ordre
judiciaire et policier monsieur Éric
Poget
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Défenseur des droits vous agissez en
tant qu'organe de contrôle externe des
forces de sécurité comme indiquées dans
le chapitre 5 de votre rapport voici mon
intervention concernera le sujet des
violences faites aux policiers
durant les récents mouvements contre la
réforme des retraites nous avons assisté
à de véritables scènes de guérilla
urbaine et les rapports de gendarmerie
sur ses affrontements sont hélas
éloquents
du côté des casseurs et des manifestants
les plus radicaux usage de cocktail
Molotov mortier d'artifice mélange
incendiaire boules de pétanque pavés
projetées sur les forces de l'ordre des
centaines de blessés sont à déplorer
dans leur rang dont certains très
gravement je pense notamment à ce CRS
enflammé par un cocktail Molotov dans
les images ont fait la une des médias
du côté des forces de l'ordre certaines
violences disproportionnées doivent être
clairement et fermement sanctionnés mais
l'expression générique de violences
policières laissent à penser qu'elles
sont un phénomène généralisé dans notre
pays et la sémantique à une valeur
symbolique
c'est loin d'être le cas et vous même
avez déclaré que sur la centaine de cas
de violence des forces de l'ordre dont
vous avez été saisies quatre seulement
on fait l'objet d'une saisine d'office
de votre part
de plus le bilan judiciaire des
manifestants interpellés est faible avec
40% des gardes à vue seulement suivis de
poursuites ce bilan étant établi je
souhaite rappeler que de par votre
fonction il vous incombe la mission de
contribuer à protéger les droits
fondamentaux des citoyens y compris ceux
des forces de l'ordre vous avez dénoncé
dernièrement des images inadmissibles et
extrêmement choquantes selon vos propres
termes d'actes de violence commis par
les forces de l'ordre
aussi ma question sera simple comment
qualifieriez-vous les images de violence
subies par les policiers et les
gendarmes je vous remercie
merci Madame Blandine brocard
merci à Monsieur le Président Madame la
Défenseur des droits
j'ai lu à votre apport évidemment avec
attention il est naturellement très
utile en sens qu'il pointe des
dysfonctionnements sur lesquels nous
devons travailler vous en avez et lancer
un certain nombre mais je dois avouer
que sa lecture me laisse quand même une
certaine amertume car il ne fait souvent
que pointer certes des
dysfonctionnements mais sans mettre en
balance les avancées conséquentes faites
pour fluidifier l'exercice de certains
droits alors par exemple si je suis
absolument d'accord avec vous sur le
fait qu'il soit nécessaire de pouvoir
joindre une administration et que tous
ici même en tant que Français on est
exaspéré quand on parvient pas à joindre
une administration il me semble aussi
intéressant de pointer les avancées des
droits que génère aussi la
dématérialisation alors par exemple la
pré plainte en ligne elle renforce
considérablement les droits de beaucoup
avec une pratique inverse et on ne va
plus faire de la gendarmerie on prépare
sa plainte et un gendarme nous rappelle
pour prendre un rendez-vous alors certes
comme vous le pointez une partie du
travail autrefois dévoluer à
l'administration et déportés sur
l'usager mais le principal bénéficiaire
en est quand même l'usagé parce qu'il
peut engager beaucoup plus facilement
une démarche pour faire valoir ses
droits sans les freins des placements
heures d'ouverture qui aboutissaient
bien souvent à l'abandon de ladite des
démarches je tiens d'ailleurs à
souligner que si le nombre de plaintes
et de réclamations est en augmentation
ce n'est pas non plus forcément que le
nombre d'atteintes au droit les
également et vous reconnaissez
d'ailleurs page 45 de votre apport le
bénéfice apporté par la plateforme
anti-discrimination.fr qui a permis une
augmentation des saisines de 26% saisine
qui n'auraient pas été faites par
ailleurs
aussi madame j'aimerais vous entendre
sur ce qui va mieux sur les secteurs sur
lesquels vous avez moins de difficultés
sur ce qui marche plutôt pas mal et qui
ne marchait pas auparavant je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur Hervé Solignac
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Défenseur des droits j'ai comme tout le
monde ici évidemment lui votre rapport
d'activité et je voudrais revenir un
instant sur le focus que vous faites
page 66 relatif à l'intelligence
artificielle vous mettez en évidence les
risques représentent l'IA pour nos
droits et le besoin de renforcer notre
cas juridique l'Union européenne il
travaille vous avez également réalisé
une enquête d'opinion qui montre le
déficit d'information et la prise de
conscience insuffisante de la part de
nos concitoyens et vous faites un
certain nombre de recommandations et
votre travail est très centré sur les
questions de de biométrique or la
question de l'intelligence artificielle
a déjà un impact majeur sur nos droits
et ces usages vont se déployer très vite
dans notre vie quotidienne et cela à
court terme alors être en réaction à ce
qui existe évidemment
utile mais vous avez dit vous-même dans
votre propos introductif que votre
institution était aussi là pour alerter
prévenir et pas toujours réparer et je
partage évidemment ce point de vue
s'agissant de l'intelligence
artificielle je pense à deux droits
manager qu'elle va percuter de plein
fouet d'abord le droit au travail dont
je rappelle qu'il est inscrit dans notre
Constitution comme dans le droit
européen et international certains
chercheurs américains estiment que à
moyen terme 80% des emplois pourraient
disparaître à la suite de l'usage de
cette intelligence artificielle et puis
l'accès aux services publics que vous
avez longuement évoqué et vous évoquez
souvent à chaque fois que vous venez
faire la présentation de votre apport
d'activité la dématérialisation qui a
dégradé pour ne pas dire déshumaniser
notre service public j'indique
évidemment que l'intelligence
artificielle peut constituer un
accélérateur considérable de ce
phénomène de dégradation et donc ma
question est simple est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas nécessaire que le Défenseur
des droits soit proactif sur ces
questions pour essayer de prévenir le
Big Bang auquel on peut s'attendre
s'agissant des effets de l'intelligence
artificielle sur notre vie quotidienne
et sur nos services je vous remercie
merci des informations pour la
commission des lois à ce titre bien nous
avions un comité de suivi de la Love Me
sur lequel toutes les innovations
technologiques ont été présentées au
parlementaires j'invite les
parlementaires à suivre les comités de
suivi de la lotmi puisque ils sont assez
importants sur les questions du
déploiement des outils numériques dans
le cadre des services publics deuxième
élément sur la question de l'information
de l'intelligence artificielle pardon
une mission d'information a été nommée
par notre commission sur l'intelligence
artificielle générative sur les libertés
publiques et sur la protection des
données qui sont acquises elle est au
rapport de Monsieur Stéphane Rambaud et
de Monsieur Philippe Pradal elle doit
rendre ses conclusions d'ici 6 mois
madame NEMA Moutchou
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Défenseur des droits je voudrais vous
interroger sur un autre public
vulnérable que l'actualité ne doit pas
nous faire oublier ce sont les enfants
et doublement vulnérable en ce qui
concerne les enfants qui sont atteints
de troubles du neurodéveloppement je
crois que c'est un enfant sur 6 dans
notre pays et puis en particulier ceux
qui sont porteurs de troubles du spectre
de l'autisme il y a une réelle détresse
des familles sur l'accompagnement la
prise en charge la
l'inclusion dans l'école l'inclusion
réussie j'insiste réussie dans l'école
et c'est une détresse qui n'est pas
étonnante quand on voit un certain
nombre de données puisque nous avons un
rapport de 2018 de la Cour des comptes
qui souligne la faiblesse de l'accès au
diagnostic de l'autisme en France et
d'autres pathologies psychiatriques
souvent associées on sait que les prises
en charge sont souvent trop hétérogènes
dans les territoires alors c'est c'est
lié à l'accès aux soins évidemment et en
ce qui concerne les enfants à l'accès au
Service de Protection Maternelle et
Infantile et pour donner un chiffre les
délais d'attentes pour obtenir un simple
rendez-vous auprès d'un Centre de
Ressources Autisme vont parfois jusqu'à
18 mois évidemment c'est beaucoup
beaucoup trop long et il y a des marges
de progression la délégué
interministérielle à l'autisme rappelle
que ces situations créent une perte de
chance de voir le handicap s'améliorer
faute de prise en charge précoce nous
savons qu'une prise en charge avant
quatre ans trois ans permet d'améliorer
de manière significative le
développement et l'autonomie de l'enfant
avec évidemment des répercussions
ensuite sur l'ensemble de sa vie
ça c'est sur l'aspect prise en charge
sur l'aspect scolaire sur la scolarité
réussite ses enfants alors il y a une
augmentation du nombre d'aesh et c'est
très bien mais il y a un autre point
crucial qui n'est pas toujours abordé
c'est à mon sens la coopération entre le
secteur médico-social et les
établissements scolaires ce lien entre
les domaines éducatifs et sanitaires est
essentiel si nous voulons résoudre à
long terme le problème des inégalités
territoriales et sociales d'accès à la
santé alors des efforts ont été faits
des plans sont mis en oeuvre il y a
encore récemment des annonces du
président de la République je voudrais
vous demander madame la Défenseur des
droits quels sont vos recommandations
prioritaires je vous remercie merci
Monsieur Benjamin Lucas
c'est Lucas
c'est bon merci bien moi je veux d'abord
saluer votre action et le rôle précieux
du défenseur des droites son
indépendance particulièrement dans un
moment où l'État de droit et les
libertés publiques sont affaiblies par
ce la même qui ont mission de les
garantir plus qu'une question je veux
que nous entendions nous parlementaire
votre alerte sur l'accès aux services
publics alerte qui corroborent ce que
nous vivons chacune et chacun chaque
jour partout dans le pays nous devrions
nous législateur trembler de honte à la
lecture de votre rapport à l'écoute de
votre exposé linéaire il n'y en effet
pas de liberté d'égalité ou de
fraternité possible sans traduction
concrète de cette devise qui est une
promesse républicaine dans l'axé
quotidien des citoyens au démarche les
plus essentielles et dans leur accès au
service public
notamment pour les plus vulnérables et
je pense au plus précaire aux exilés la
dématérialisation la réduction de la
présence humaine des services publics
sur tous les territoires est une
discrimination brutale et insupportable
l'état organise le recours pour faire
des économies et plus que de s'y être
résignés de son accommoder il organise
et suscite selon recours et là aussi
c'est un scandale social et démocratique
et enfin monsieur le Président puisque
vous ne l'avez pas fait moi je vais le
faire et amputer une partie de ma
question mais quand même je crois que ça
doit être relevé après ce qu'a dit le
rassemblement national qui nous montre
d'ailleurs ce que serait une politique
d'extrême droite à la tête du pays sans
prendre à ceux qui défendent nos droits
nos libertés fondamentales qui font
preuve d'indépendance à l'égard des
pouvoirs politiques quels qu'ils soient
je crois qu'il n'est pas acceptable il
n'est pas acceptable monsieur le
Président de laisser au sein de la
commission des lois dit Famer une
institution comme celle-ci ça
représentante la Défenseur des droits je
crois que c'est inacceptable et que vous
ne pouvez pas rester silencieux quand il
y a une telle attaque qui est faite de
la part des collègues du rassemblement
national de tels canonie de tels injures
de telles diffamations je crois que ce
n'est pas à la hauteur de l'esprit
démocratique et de l'esprit républicain
qui devrait prévaloir dans cet enceinte
monsieur Lucas monsieur Lucas en fait
ici c'est moi qui préside la séance et
c'est moi qui décide des règles de
police de police de la séance ça ne vous
plaît pas voilà ça ne vous plaît pas non
plus quand j'interviens dans le débat
donc libre à moi de faire la séance
comme je le souhaite madame la Défenseur
des droits madame la Défenseur des
droits répondra voilà et donc pour le
coup chacun dans cette commission est
libre de ses propos et doit les assumer
à l'extérieur par ailleurs
monsieur Timothée Houssin
merci Madame la Défenseur des droits ma
question portera sur les mineurs non
accompagnés ceux qu'on appelle les
mineurs accompagnés que vous évoquez à
la page 78 de votre rapport et qui sont
en fait des clandestins entrée
illégalement sur notre territoire et se
déclarant car c'est purement déclaratif
mineur et son apparence sur le
territoire le ministère de la Justice
nous dit qu'ils sont
19893 à être pris en charge par les
départements et donc par le contribuable
au titre de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
l'Assemblée des départements de France
nous indique le coût de cette prise en
charge qui est de 50000 euros par an et
par personne cependant depuis maintenant
de nombreuses années les rapports
sénatoriaux l'émission d'information les
études se succèdent pour nous dire que
60 à 90% de ces bénéficiaires sont en
réalité des majeurs c'est à dire des
fraudeurs au statut de MNA alors pour
être relativement consensuel dans le
calcul qu'on va faire on va prendre le
chiffre qui est validé par le service
check news de libération qui nous dit
qu'il y a 60% de fraudeur donc on a une
fraude massive on a des sources
sérieuses qui la documentent et on a au
bas mot une fraude qui représente 596
millions d'euros par an donc vous qui
êtes Défenseur des droits que
pensez-vous finalement de cette abus de
droit que pensez-vous de ce chiffre de
596 millions d'euros de cette fraude
massive qu'est-ce que vous préconisez
comme moyen de contrôle pour éviter
cette fraude et puis mais ne pensez-vous
pas que cette situation que cette
gabegie qui perdure maintenant depuis
des années se fait au détriment des
vrais mineurs au détriment des
politiques comme les foyers de l'enfance
au détriment de la prise en charge du
handicap dont vous disiez tout à l'heure
à juste titre qu'elle manquait de moyens
au détriment de l'accès aux soins au
détriment de budget peut-être pour les
services publics de proximité au
détriment finalement d'autant de droits
que vous avez à défendre qui devrait
être des priorités et qui ont bien
besoin de budget et de ses 596 millions
d'euros qui sont gaspillés mais la
melzaf aussi
merci monsieur le Président je crois
aussi comme mon collègue Benjamin Lucas
que comme législateur ce qui doit nous
préoccuper en permanence c'est comment
améliorer les droits de nos concitoyens
mais aussi de devoir constater contrôler
la distorsion entre la loi et le fait et
nous constatons
par à la fois tout le travail que nous
menons d'audition etc mais aussi le
travail en circonscription que que nous
menons la distorsion entre la loi et le
fait et elle doit avoir toute notre
attention et l'institution qui est le
Défenseur des droits est un des outils
également qui nous permet et bien de
pouvoir recenser ces distorsions ou des
dispositions qui pourraient permettre en
tant que législateur
d'améliorer les droits de nos
concitoyens
un peu peut-être comme la Défenseur des
droits généralement les gens qui me
passent des coups de fil dans ma
circonscription ça arrive qu'il me
disent qu'il m'aime beaucoup mais la
plupart du temps il m'appelle surtout
pour me dire ce qui ne va pas et ce
qu'il rencontre comme difficulté leur en
travaux droits et d'ailleurs ce n'est
pas
c'est votre mission principale c'est
votre raison d'être donc je me doute que
c'est là-dessus que vous vous penchez
un peu plus encore que vous moi je
constate que c'est un peu plus de 50%
des appels qui sont faits sur la
question de la dématérialisation est
très en particulier sur la question des
droits des étrangers tant leur
vulnérabilité devant cette
dématérialisation elle nous alerte pour
l'ensemble de la population
et ce que je vois c'est que les choses
ont quand même beaucoup de mal à
s'améliorer à être amélioré beaucoup de
mal encore aujourd'hui et ce qui est
vrai c'est que ça crée et bien des gens
ça remet des gens dans l'irrides les
régularités alors même qu'ils ont un
parcours avec des titres de séjour un
travail une scolarisation des enfants et
j'ai été bien témoin de très nombreux
cas de personnes et bien qui soit
perdaient des droits soit perdés leur
emploi donc j'aimerais que vous nous
préconisiez aussi en tant que
législateur des dispositions permettant
d'améliorer ses droits madame la
Défenseur des droits pour répondre à
cette première série de questions
merci je vais prendre à peu près les
questions dans l'ordre même si quand
c'est plusieurs fois sur l'enfance je le
ferai dans dans la globalité sur la
question de de la protection de
l'enfance ce que nous ce que nous
observons c'est d'abord je vous l'avais
dit et une augmentation de nos une
augmentation de nos saisines et des
saisines qui sont sur des problèmes liés
à l'éducation petite enfance scolarité
et je pense entre autres à
aux questions de d'enfants étrangers qui
n'ont pas forcément accès à l'éducation
en une grosse partie aussi des
réclamations concernent la protection de
l'enfance et l'autre partie c'est plutôt
sur les questions de santé et donc axer
des questions de handicap et entre
autres taxé à la à la scolarité les
ce qui nous frappe sur la question de la
protection de l'enfance en ce moment
c'est des inexécutions de décision de
justice d'alerte qui nous ont été faits
par des magistrats là-dessus des
ruptures de parcours des changements de
famille
de famille d'accueil sur la question que
vous posez très précisément des
violences intra familiales dans le
détail de nos de nos décisions on peut
on ne sort pas cet élément là on sort le
problème euh avec la protection de
l'enfance mais pas forcément très
précisément celui-là vous élargissiez
votre question à la question de la
discrimination dans son victime les
femmes et la question de la grossesse
c'était mon rapport d'étonnement quand
je suis arrivé dans cet institution du
nombre de décisions qu'on pouvait rendre
sur des retours de congé maternité alors
qu'on a une loi qui est en fait assez à
la fois assez claire et assez
protectrice et d'ailleurs on a refait du
coup un rapport justement pour expliquer
à la fois aux femmes et aux employeurs
quels sont quels sont les droits donc
nous avons régulièrement effectivement
des des femmes alors plutôt dans le
privé qui sont licenciés retour de congé
maternité ou qui ne retrouve pas un
poste équivalent à salaire équivalent on
retrouve aussi votre question était
intéressante sur la question de la
fonction publique des discriminations
qu'il a sont plutôt sur des non
renouvellement de de CDD qui au moment
de l'annonce de la de la grossesse ne
sont pas ne sont pas renouvelés je suis
assez impressionné que ça perdure à ce
point là il y a une nécessité de
communiquer là-dessus et de redire aux
femmes qu'elles sont leurs droits même
si un certain nombre de personnes et on
le comprend n'osent pas apporter de
réclamation parce que on peur des peur
des représailles dans votre question il
y avait aussi la question de la
médiation effectivement les trois car
aboutisses qu'est-ce qu'on fait des 25%
en dernier on laisse pas les les
personnes au bord du au bord du chemin
mais enfin la médiation il faut que
l'organisme est mise en cause accepte de
négocier c'est pas toujours le cas et
quand les situations sont
particulièrement
injustes flagrantes nous nous je dirais
dans ces cas-là les la réclamation
remonte au siège et traité par nos
juristes et nous essayons de rendre une
décision en faisant des recommandations
mais vous savez que nos recommandations
n'ont pas de pouvoir de contraintes mais
nous avons la possibilité du rapport
spécial c'est-à-dire la publication au
Journal officiel en nommant l'organisme
la mise en cause et ça nous est arrivé
de le faire et nous et nous continuons
d'ailleurs à le faire et notre autre
possibilité c'est aussi des observations
devant les tribunaux où je le rappelle
nous sommes suivis dans plus de 80% des
cas par par les tribunaux ça me permet
aussi de répondre à la deuxième question
sur les enfants et les troubles de
neurodéveloppement ce que nous observons
effectivement c'est beaucoup de
difficultés d'accès à l'école l'accès au
temps méridien c'est à dire tout ce qui
est de la cantine une fois que l'accès à
l'école a été réglé c'est pas forcément
l'accès à la cantine qui a été réglé et
ça met les maires souvent plus celle en
situation très difficile parce que s'il
faut récupérer l'enfant à l'heure du
déjeuner comment vous arrivez à
travailler dans dans ces conditions et
des difficultés vous l'avez souligné des
difficultés d'accès aux soins et les
difficultés d'accès aux soins qu'on
remarque en pédiatrie et en
pédopsychiatrie de façon absolument
massive inquiétante nous avions rendu
notre rapport annuel il y a deux ans sur
le rapport annuel enfant sur la question
de la santé mentale des enfants
honnêtement il y a pas de progrès ce
qu'on voit dans nos réclamations c'est
plutôt plutôt une aggravation il y a
urgence à agir enfin si on veut qu'on
ait une jeunesse qui aille bien il faut
qu'elle puisse être prise en charge
quand il y a quand il y a des des
difficultés
sur les questions
déontologie
le
je suis impressionné des attaques contre
l'institution et puis je les entends
bien des attaques contre ma personne je
l'ai bien perçu ne vous inquiétez pas
cet institution est inscrite dans la
Constitution ce n'est pas pour rien elle
est indépendante oui le mode de
nomination et le fait que je sois non
révocable et non renouvelable est une
force pour l'institution et une
indépendance donc oui je suis
parfaitement indépendante alors
évidemment il y a des choses qui ne vous
plaisent pas dans ce que je dis mais il
y a des choses qui plaisent pas non plus
au gouvernement ça vous ça vous
intéresse quand je parle de difficultés
d'accès aux services publics vous n'êtes
pas content quand je parle des
déontologies des forces de sécurité mais
c'est absolument indispensable toute
démocratie à un contrôle externe de la
déontologie des forces de sécurité c'est
juste indispensable la référence auquel
vous madame sur les propos qui ont été
tenus dans des tracts de la
pénitentiaire je pense j'espère que vous
avez lu les tracts parce qu'ils sont
quand même absolument inadmissibles que
je vous rappelle que le racisme est un
délit et qu'il est condamné qu'on ne
peut pas accepter ce genre de propos et
tout ça ne m'empêche pas de considérer
que les lassituation des surveillants
pénitentiaires est excessivement
difficile et je le dis je le dis aussi
sur les forces de l'ordre qui travaille
dans des conditions particulièrement
difficiles avec une surpopulation
carcérale dont c'est eux aussi et pas
simplement la détenus qui paye les frais
donc oui je le dis et donc quand vous me
dites que je ne les défends pas mais
absolument je continue à le dire et dans
mes visites en détention je suis outré
de ce que j'observe ou très des
conditions dans son maintenues les
détenus et qui évidemment génère de la
violence les directeurs des centres
pénitentiaires le disent bien quand ils
sont à trois dans une cellule avec des
matelas par terre et qu'ils dans moins
de 10 mètres carrés c'est absolument
inadmissible et évidemment que ça génère
de la violence mais aucun moment ça
excuse des propos qui sont diffamatoires
à aucun moment quoi qu'il arrive quel
que soit les conditions de travail ça
excuse parce que dans ces cas-là on va
l'excuser jusqu'où on va l'excuser aussi
alors dans les hôpitaux et dans les
protections de l'enfance parce qu'ils
sont en difficulté non nous continuerons
à dire que la maltraitance elle se joue
à tous les niveaux et que c'est
absolument inadmissible je continue sur
les et je vous vous êtes allés jusqu'à
dire que je contribue à la haine je
trouve ça alors absolument fort de café
parce que vraiment nous contribuerons en
justement disant les moments où il y a
des excès et on ne généralisant
absolument jamais à aucun moment je n'ai
généralisé à tout moment j'ai condamné
toute forme de violence donc je ne
absolument aucun problème là-dessus nous
contribuons au contraire en disant ce
qu'il ne va pas en montrant les endroits
où ça ne va pas à rétablir la confiance
dans nos dans nos institutions et la
confiance dans la dans la police et je
pense que si ça vous échappe que dans
toute démocratie il y a un contrôle
externe de la déontologie des forces de
sécurité c'est quelque peu inquiétant
sur
sur la question des des des
la question des manifestations
la liberté de manifester
la liberté de manifester est absolument
indispensable et là je reviens à ce que
je vous ai dit dans mon propos
introductif nous venons donc d'avoir nos
en sommes à 165 réclamations il va nous
falloir un certain temps pour mener ses
enquêtes et donc là je sur la question
des manifestations depuis le mois de
janvier en dehors de fait absolument
scandaleux que nous avons
observé je ne me prononcerai pas pour
l'instant nous attendons de pouvoir
mener nos enquêtes en contradictoires et
évidemment cela va prendre cela va
prendre un certain temps je
reviens sur je poursuis sur la question
de la déontologie des forces de sécurité
d'abord je l'ai dit et dans toutes nos
interventions je le dis je contane tout
acte de violence et j'ai une pensée pour
les blessés après si ça vous a échappé
que nous sommes en charge de la
déontologie des forces de sécurité mais
pas de la violence des manifestants je
suis désolé la loi nous a chargé de la
déontologie des forces de sécurité pas
de la question de la violence des
manifestants la violence des
manifestants c'est devant la justice que
ça doit se passer je suis désolé ça
n'est pas dans nos attributions la loi
est très précise sur cette sur cette sur
cette question là vous l'avez dit nous
nous sommes saisis nous avons fait
quatre saisons d'office le reste ce sont
des réclamations qui nous arrivent je
oui est-ce que vous pouvez retrouver
votre calme deux minutes qu'on puisse
écouter les réponses aux questions que
vous avez posées
merci dans nos dans nos enquêtes ce que
nous allons analyser c'est le respect de
la déontologie c'est l'usage nécessaire
et proportionné de la de la force
les réclamations que nous recevons les
166 portes en gros sur des personnes qui
se plaignent d'avoir été privées de
liberté dans des Nass de personnes qui
disent avoir été victime de violence des
personnes avec des interpellations
suivies de garde à vue considérés par
les réclamants comme arbitraires et la
nouveauté je tiens à le dire c'est des
réclamations de journalistes empêché
dans leur travail et là-dessus nous
continuerons nous avons besoin de mener
des enquêtes en contradictoires je vous
je vous l'ai dit et
il nous faudra un certain temps c'est
parfaitement c'est parfaitement normal
je redis que notre institution elle
contribue à la confiance en justement
montrant les moments où il y a eu
particulièrement des difficultés et des
atteintes à la déontologie des forces
des forces de sécurité vous m'avez
madame interpellé sur le fait que
l'institution ne souligne pas les
progrès mais oui mais alors c'est
comment vous dire nous sommes un
observatoire de ce qui ne va pas les
réclamations c'est vraiment la base
c'est les réclamations de ski ne va pas
et nous nous sommes pas en capacité en
fait d'évaluer les progrès d'abord la
loi ne nous confie pas ce travail là ça
c'est vraiment la première chose la
deuxième c'est que on n'est pas en
capacité de le faire par exemple le fait
d'être présent dans une centaine de
français services ne nous permet pas
d'évaluer l'ensemble des Francs service
et nous permet de dire à certains
endroits ce qu'on observe dans nos
réclamations mais que dans nos
réclamations donc oui à chaque fois je
suis désolé je continue à voir ce qui ne
va pas sur la dématérialisation je l'ai
dit là et je le dis à chaque fois que
j'interviens sur la dématérialisation je
dis que c'est une chance et je dis
simplement ce que j'observe mais quand
vous avez un tiers de la population qui
t'éloignée du numérique on ne peut pas
ne pas prendre ça en compte et puis
chacun d'entre nous c'est un jour
retrouver en difficulté parce que le
site bug parce que on arrive à joindre à
joindre personne donc et sur le site
vous avez cité vous en a bien créé anti
discrimination.fr mais justement on a
mis des gens aussi au bout du fil et
avec des et avec des personnes formées
juridiquement qui sont capables de
passer trois quarts d'heure avec les
réclamants quand c'est nécessaire donc
et surtout quand elle le veulent les on
leur dit quand ils appellent vous pouvez
aller voir physiquement à nos délégués
donc le c'est vraiment le site internet
et en soi est une bonne chose nous avons
un site Internet nous avons la
possibilité de nous saisir sur le site
internet mais nous ce que nous ce qu'on
dit c'est que il faut cette possibilité
mais il faut aussi la possibilité d'une
rencontre physique et je vous je vous
redis aussi là-dessus la décision du
Conseil d'État qui est très intéressant
sur les préfectures qui dit bien que en
l'état actuel des difficultés la
possibilité de déposer un dossier papier
est indispensable je suis d'ailleurs
quelque peu étonné que la décision ne
soit pas encore appliquée si je puis me
si je puis me permettre sur
la question de l'intelligence
artificielle alors vous avez tout à fait
raison nous nous suivons ce sujet de
très près entre autres le règlement de
le règlement européen sur l'intelligence
artificielle qui est en cours de
négociation notre notre axe c'est le
respect des droits fondamentaux des
inquiétudes sur la discrimination qui
peut être accentuée à la fois au départ
mais aussi dans le fonctionnement de
cette intelligence artificielle donc si
nous sommes tout à fait proactifs nous
suivons de près entre guillemets avec
nos petits moyens et là je peux vous
dire que c'est effectivement avec nos
petits moyens mais effectivement ça nous
avons aussi des des inquiétudes sur les
mineurs d'un accompagné les mineurs sont
accompagnés sont d'abord des mineurs ce
sont d'abord sur une grande partie ce
sont d'abord des mineurs et qui ont
besoin d'être protégés et c'est la
première chose que nous disons qui ont
droit à la protection et mon inquiétude
ce sont les les atteintes au droit de
ces mineurs de séminaires non accompagné
dans ce que nous observons ou des
mineurs tout à fait mineurs ne sont pas
accompagnés et d'autre part mettre en
opposition des précarités alors là je
peux vous dire et j'ai une petite
expérience dans le domaine c'est que ça
se retourne toujours contre les plus
pauvres et contre les plus pauvres quel
que soit leur origine et donc monter les
populations et monter les enfants qui en
difficulté les uns contre les autres en
faisant une opposition entre des MNA et
des mineurs qui sont en protection de
l'enfance et ben non justement c'est
aussi délétère sur les mineurs qui sont
qui sont en protection de l'enfance que
vous vous qualifiez de français et dont
il faudrait seulement prendre en charge
je peux vous dire et j'ai une petite
expérience dans le domaine que ça se
retourne toujours contre les plus
pauvres quand on met ah ben non c'est
pas du tout hors sujet c'est
complètement dans le sujet et j'ai une
petite une petite expérience
alors vous n'avez pas la parole c'est la
parole à la Défenseur des droits vous
avez déposé vos questions maintenant les
réponses merci sur la dernière question
qui a qui a été posée sur la distorsion
entre finalement la loi et sa réelle et
sa réelle application
oui c'est exactement ce que nous
observons et je suis assez intéressé sur
ce que vous venez de dire parce que dans
vos permanences vous observez les mêmes
choses que ce qu'on observe je n'ai pas
de doute et c'est d'ailleurs très
intéressant à chaque fois qu'on échange
avec vous là dessus c'est que vous avez
le même genre de réclamation que ce
qu'on peut que ce qu'on peut avoir vous
êtes aussi là-dessus d'ailleurs vos
permanences sont d'ailleurs très utile
pour ça aussi un bon observatoire et
nous on est là pour rappeler en fait
quand la loi elle est parfois trop
complexe trop compliquée ou en tout cas
pas appliquer essayer de comprendre
pourquoi et de faire un certain nombre
de de recommandations et notre rôle il
est de faire évoluer le droit par nos
propositions alors de plusieurs manières
je dis les observations que nous faisons
devant les tribunaux sont aussi une
façon de faire évoluer la jurisprudence
dans ce que nous apportons avec nos
forts pouvoirs d'enquête et des
spécialistes entre autres sur les
questions de de discrimination mais oui
l'institution elle a vraiment été créée
pour ça d'ailleurs pour cette distorsion
entre la réalité de la loi et du droit
et la réalité du terrain et cette
institution quand on se retourne sur le
à la fois je dirais sur la loi elle-même
mais sur les débats qui ont eu lieu
c'était vraiment pour ceux qui sont le
plus éloignés du droit et qui ont le
plus de mal à faire valoir leurs droits
merci Monsieur Benjamin saint tuiles
pour une nouvelle série
une question qu'elle n'avait pas répondu
vous pouvez j'avais vu que vous les avez
écrit donc
vous avez besoin de la commission
répondre à mes questions
sur la question des des lanceurs
d'alerte parce que c'est vraiment c'est
important les lanceurs d'alerte d'abord
vous dire que nous avons d'abord sorti
un guide là tout récemment et un guide à
destination entre autres de ceux qui se
pourrait se considérer comme lanceur
d'alerte pour qu'il sache justement qui
saisir comment nous saisir et s'il
rentre dans le cadre des lanceurs
d'alerte notre doctrine nous avait posé
une question sur notre doctrine elle se
construit au fur et à mesure donc là
c'est encore un peu tôt pour dire
exactement quel est notre doctrine en
revanche et nous rendrons un rapport
tous les deux ans vous savez donc là on
n'est pas encore dans le timing et 2 ans
mais nous rendrons un rapport et nous
commençons à avoir tous les ans enfin là
dès cette année des rapports des
différentes autorités aussi en charge
des lanceurs des lanceurs d'alerte et on
a un rôle d'animation des autorités
externes et sans qu'il y a déjà eu une
première rencontre avec ses autorités
côté externe et nous ferons très
régulièrement et c'est ce qui s'est dit
pendant cette rencontre nous ferons très
régulièrement
très régulièrement des des réunions avec
avec ces autorités et ses autorités
externes dans la question Antilles que
vous m'aviez posé effectivement on a une
délégation menée par Georges Paul
Langevin qui était parti fin novembre
voir la difficulté d'accès au service
public aux Antilles donc parce qu'on
avait été particulièrement alerté sur la
situation
à la fois Martinique et en Guadeloupe et
je suis retourné au mois de mars parce
qu'on a rendu notre rapport et que j'ai
voulu d'abord aller le présenter sur
place on a constaté des atteintes au
droit inquiétantes alors je pense entre
autres au droit à la pension de retraite
c'est-à-dire des personnes qui déposent
des dossiers qui passent à Nord 18 mois
sans aucune pension de retraite qui se
retrouve avec rien parce que leur
dossier sont sont bloqués simplement
enfin les de fait des agents de service
public qui ont du mal à traiter tous les
dossiers on est très inquiet sur les sur
la situation dans les dans les écoles où
il y a 20% de courant moins par rapport
à la métropole due à un certain nombre
de difficultés d'accès aux écoles à la
fois quand il y a des manifestations
quand il y a les Sargasses quand il y a
des cyclones et donc c'est 20% d'heures
de cours en moins c'est une sur le
primaire c'est une année scolaire en
moins donc c'est quand même assez
considérable et ça évidemment un impact
des difficultés aussi dans les dans les
dans les transports des difficultés
d'accès à l'eau particulièrement en
Guadeloupe mais pas que et entre des
difficultés simplement pour contester
une facture quand c'est le cas et
qu'elle est qu'elle n'est pas cohérente
et Georges Paul Langevin d'ailleurs est
auditionné cet après-midi par la
commission par la commission par la
commission d'enquête sur ces sur ces
questions là
merci beaucoup et donc monsieur Benjamin
Saint-Huile
merci monsieur le Président et merci de
m'accueillir dans cette commission je
découvre l'ambiance joviale légère et
détendue avec un certain plaisir
merci beaucoup je vous en prie madame je
disais que j'avais beaucoup de plaisir à
rejoindre cette commission jovial
détendue tout ça tout ça madame la
Défenseur des droits reconnaissons de
manière générale que ce que vous écrivez
et désagréable à lire et à entendre et
que ça doit être pour nous les éléments
d'enseignement et de fixation d'objectif
à partager en vue de l'amélioration et
donc même si parfois vous écoutez est
assez désagréable pardon ça n'est pas
l'attaque personnelle il me semble
important de conforter l'institution que
vous représentez vous avez évoqué les
moyens moi j'ai deux questions plus
précises à vous poser la première sur le
déploiement et l'allé vert
quel regard vous portez vous avez évoqué
les maisons France services vous avez
évoqué d'autres dispositifs de proximité
est-ce que vous avez un regard sur ce
qui fonctionne et ce qui fonctionne
moins et pourquoi vous êtes dans
certaines francs services et pas dans
d'autres et comment finalement vous
travaillez avec l'échelon local qu'il
s'agit des intercommunalités ou des
communes pour vérifier vos lieux
d'implantation et peut-être la connais
encore plus fine de nos administrer
concernant votre institution la deuxième
question c'est une question de moyens
vous avez parlé de la nécessité de
renforcer les moyens de votre
institution si vous deviez des prioriser
sur quel pan de l'activité vous
souhaiteriez concentrer vos moyens j'ai
entendu comme tous ici la question du
risque d'embolie sur le droit des
étrangers mais est-ce que vous pourriez
le préciser et puis en
prolongement de cette question vous avez
évoqué à plusieurs reprises le rôle des
délégués territoriaux je voudrais savoir
comment ils sont entre guillemets
recrutés formés et accompagné dans les
missions qui sont les leurs pour que
l'institution puisse avoir une action
homogène sur l'échelle du territoire
national et qui est pas trop de
différence de traitement entre d'un
territoire à l'autre je vous remercie
madame Maria
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
l'épaisseur de droite de l'ensemble non
seulement de du rapport qui a été
réalisé avec l'ensemble des vos équipes
mais aussi des réponses très claires qui
ont été apportées dans cette première
phase moi je voulais peut-être revenir
sur un des aspects du rapport qui aborde
la question de l'accès à ma prive
Grenoble puisque il est question dans ce
rapport et qui qui s'est avéré pour de
nombreux Français disons-le une galère
et que vous avez formulé des
recommandations à l'attention de Lana
savez-vous qu'elle a été donc la
réception de celle-ci c'est ma première
question
quelle mesure on peut être justement
prise pour les personnes en difficulté
de paiement de travaux faute de prise en
compte de leur dossier faite de
remboursement ou d'erreurs justement sur
des montants annoncés je reçois encore
comme je pense de nombreux collègues ici
des demandes et des plaintes comment
justement on peut les aider ça c'est ma
première la question sur la deuxième
vous avez abordé mais sur le maintien de
l'ordre il y a l'occasion de l'audition
de monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
j'avais formulé plusieurs observations
plusieurs enjeux sont identifiables
puisque la liberté de manifester est un
droit fondamental et il est il doit être
aussi lié avec la nécessaire
préservation de l'ordre public alors et
on a parlé on avait parlé de la
formation on avait parlé aussi du schéma
national du maintien de l'ordre donc qui
doit être actualisé de l'expérimentation
de la présence de médiateurs
identifiée au sein des cortèges capables
d'informer la police sous l'ambiance de
la manifestation et les manifestants et
un retour sur le contrôle opéré au titre
justement de la police administrative en
amont de manifestations est-ce que il
est important pour le Parlement qui
puisse examiner chaque année des
conditions d'exercices de ces faits que
pensez-vous de la nécessité d'en faire
des points d'appui justement pour
améliorer la situation je vous remercie
Monsieur Philippe Gosselin
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
défenseur ravie de vous accueillir quoi
qu'on pense certains vous êtes une
institution constitutionnelle je ne
partage pas loin sans faute certains de
vos propos et certaines de vos approches
mais il est important que la République
et la démocratie est si vous me
permettez l'expression peut-être un peu
triviale des poils à gratter ce sont des
regards extérieurs importants et qui
nous oblige et qui nous secoue un peu
parfois et et c'est important vous nous
secouez sur les droits des enfants vous
nous secouez sur certains éléments de
déontologie vous nous secouez sur la
déshumanisation de notre administration
au sens très large sur le droit des
enfants effectivement et sur le handicap
il y a beaucoup pas dire je relis ça
d'ailleurs à une condamnation récente de
de la France alors que je trouve pour
une part je le dis quand même excessive
parce que entendre certains à
l'extérieur rien n'irait dans ce pays
par moment j'ai envie de dire
comparaison n'est pas raison et allez
voir ailleurs et vous verrez que c'est
pas toujours si mal que ça mais un
certain nombre de difficultés
sont bien là
résistent les enfants en particulier qui
sont victimes d'un handicap ou qui
depuis des années sont en difficulté
scolaire n'ont pas toujours
l'accompagnement qui serait nécessaire
donc je serai heureux d'entendre un
certain nombre de vos propositions sur
ce sujet et puis voir aussi la question
des alternatives c'est sur la
déshumanisation de nos services publics
qui qui s'éloignent un peu je pense que
c'est d'ailleurs une cause préoccupante
de de
réaction de nos concitoyens dans les
urnes ils ont l'impression que les
services publics ont déserté qu'il y a
des déserts de service public partout
donc quelle mesure là aussi même si vous
avez déjà commencé à répondre avec la
première salle de questions quelles
mesures pour assurer davantage des
alternatives en saluant c'est vrai aussi
l'intérêt de la dématérialisation
jamais la nécessité aussi d'avoir un
guichet où on peut s'adresser
physiquement à quelqu'un il faut aller
vers sans aucun doute mais il faut aussi
être ouvert je me suis Handica Watt
merci monsieur le Président donc Madame
la Défenseur des droits ce qui est rare
est précieux et les institutions
indépendantes comme la vôtre sont rares
votre présentation du rapport dont nous
allons tous la richesse et la rigueur
nous arrive en cette journée symbolique
de lutte mondiale contre les violences
LGBT et au food du farahop en passant
par la libération de la parole des
victimes les évolutions du droit ont
beau été avoir conquis de haute lutte
par les gays les lesbiennes et les trans
les associations nous donnent un constat
unanime l'horizon d'API sans actes
lgbt-fobe est encore bien loin les
ressources allouées à la défense de ses
droits et aux associations sont encore
précaires malgré leur nécessité face aux
carences de l'État la haine monte le
rapport SOS Homophobie d'hier annonce
plus 27% d'agression sur les personnes
LGBT par rapport à l'année dernière la
Fondation Jean Jaurès une hausse de 53%
de signalement depuis 2021 et les
témoignages de victimes de François bi
explosent dans la famille à l'école dans
la rue en entreprise ou encore dans les
services publics quand on est victime de
LGBTI phobie la haine imprennent tous
les aspects de la vie elle est une
spirale d'isolement de honte de douleur
et de violence je pense à Guillaume
piégé et victime de torture pendant 3
jours Hakim à d'autres ans qui reçoit
les coups et les insultes répétés de son
père
ARANE professeur stigmatisé et mis au
bord par ses collègues et sa direction à
Coralie jeunes lesbienne outée par la
fille ont été amoureuse et roué de coups
au collège je pense à des milliers
d'autres qui pétrifiaient ce thèse nous
nous pensons à ces gens là
dans la fonction l'administration
publique tant de changement reste à
faire le personnel de l'éducation
nationale les personnels de l'Éducation
nationale sont inégalement sensibilisés
et formés et ne savent pas toujours
prévenir identifier face aux actes
lgbtophobes dans la police malgré les
promesses la pratique évolue n'évolue à
la marge la dilkra est si impuissante et
forme trop peu d'argent la parole des
victimes peut bien se libérer les
recours devant votre institution se
multiplier rien ne changera tant que des
agents de police refuseront de prendre
les plaintes relativement ou se
permettront des remarques et des
humiliations lgbtophobes j'ai une seule
question c'est qu'on voit dans le
rapport que il y a peu de saisie sur les
discriminations telles que vous avez pu
amener à l'inverse des associations qui
nous amènent beaucoup d'informations
pourquoi avons-nous mais peu de recours
à votre droit sur les violences
lgbtophobes monsieur Yohan Gillet
oui madame la Défenseur des droits dans
votre rapport annuel vous alerter sur la
dégradation des droits des personnes
étrangères vous indiquez dans votre
rapport à juste titre qu'un nombre
croissant de préfecture a fait le choix
de dématérialiser un certain nombre de
démarches et notamment les démarches de
prise de rendez-vous les
dysfonctionnements sont nombreux vous
avez raison de l'indiquer du fait de ces
dysfonctionnements vous l'écrivez dans
votre rapport de nombreux étrangers en
situation régulière se retrouvent
temporairement en situation irrégulière
mais vous oubliez en revanche d'indiquer
une autre conséquence de cette
dysfonctionnement de plus en plus
d'étrangers qui séjournent
irrégulièrement en France qui n'ont
jamais été en situation régulière
profite de ses dysfonctionnements pour
rester en France au prétexte que leur
dossier n'a pas pu être instruit il est
indéniable que le gouvernement est
complètement incapable de répondre aux
enjeux migratoires votre rapport
d'activité 2022 confirme ce triste
constant ma question est la suivante à
partir du traitement quotidien des
réclamations que vous recevez êtes-vous
en mesure de présenter plus en détail
les défaillances qui affectent les
services préfectoraux en charge des
étrangers vous parliez tout à l'heure
des problèmes d'effectif c'est une cause
que je partage c'est une raison que je
partage le nombre d'étrangers en France
qu'ils soient en situation régulière ou
irrégulière qui est en perpétuelle
augmentation a aussi un impact est-ce
que vous pouvez évaluer également assez
ces éléments là dans les conséquences de
ces des fonctionnements avez-vous des
éléments sur l'évolution des délais
moyen de traitement des dossiers des
personnes étrangères et enfin comment en
votre qualité de défenseur des droits
suivez-vous les actions concrètes du
gouvernement à la matière merci Madame
Clara chassagnol
madame la Défenseur des droits déjà je
tenais à vous remercier à la fois pour
vos réponses pour votre travail celui de
vos équipes et pour votre indépendance
dans des plaisent à nos collègues du
rassemblement national et je vous
remercie sincèrement pour les propos que
vous avez pu avoir en réponse en cette
Journée internationale de lutte contre
l'homophobie et la transphobie je tenais
à rappeler que notre mobilisation en
faveur des droits des personnes LGBT
doit continuer à être une priorité dans
votre rapport les réclamations liées à
ces discriminations en raison de
l'orientation sexuelle ou de l'identité
de genre représente 2% pour chacun de
ces critères donc une faible proportion
qui justifie probablement que le sujet
est assez peu abordé ou peut détaillé en
tout cas dans le rapport malgré notre
détermination pour lutter contre ces
discriminations et les préjugés qui leur
sont attachés les chiffres du ministère
de l'Intérieur publier l'an dernier
faisait état d'une augmentation de 28%
par rapport à 2020 et ça a été dit les
associations qui accompagnent les
personnes victimes d'homophobie ou de
transphobie témoignent aussi d'une
augmentation des sollicitations et des
agressions sachant que très peu portent
plainte ou au fond valoir leurs droits
un nouveau plan de lutte contre les LGBT
phobies et la transphobie est
actuellement en cours d'élaboration avec
les associations et le ministère de
l'Égalité aussi je souhaitais vous
interroger sur les fringues que vous
avez pu identifier dans l'accès aux
droits de ces personnes des personnes
qui vous avez sollicité et si vous aviez
des jeunes voir des mineurs qui vous
contactaient ce qu'on sait que face à
ces discriminations ils sont aussi les
plus vulnérables et en color roller
pensez-vous que le faible nombre de
saisines que vous recevez soit lié à un
manque d'information
et comment pourrait-on garantir en tout
cas améliorer pour les victimes de
discrimination les moyens pour garantir
leur protection qu'elle soit soutenue et
qu'elle soit mieux défendues je vous
remercie
monsieur Roger Vico
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
dimension des droits jouets moi aussi
rendre hommage à vos travaux qui
[Musique]
votre prédécesseur monsieur tout bon
avait adressé au ministère de
l'Intérieur dans une décision de juillet
2020 un certain nombre de
recommandations pour améliorer l'accès
aux préfectures pour les étrangers
est-ce que vous pouvez nous éclairer sur
les suites qui ont été données à ces
recommandations qui date de 3 ans
maintenant et j'ai une dernière question
monsieur le Président de la Commission
et évoqué tout à l'heure le comité de
suivi de la loop me parmi les les
[Musique]
recommandations plutôt les les suites de
la loop me il y a la une commission de
[Musique]
de contrôle de la loopy est-ce que la
Défenseur des droits est associée aux
travaux de cette commission d'une
manière ou d'une autre voilà merci
merci Monsieur Thomas porte
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Défenseur des droits et je voulais
évidemment à mon tour vous remercier
pour vos prises de position que ce soit
notamment dans le cadre de la réforme
des retraite et du mouvement social et
de la répression policière et aussi sur
la question de la Ligue des droits de
l'Homme suite aux propos de plusieurs
membres du gouvernement depuis le début
de la mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites nous avons dénoncé un usage
injustifié et disproportionné de la
force souvent sans possibilité de
contrôle des agents concernés car ils ne
portaient pas le Rio
c'est pourquoi ma question va porter sur
le respect des règles de déontologie par
les policiers et notamment le port du
Rio qui est le numéro d'identification
individuel que doivent porter de manière
visible les policiers et les gendarmes
beaucoup d'organisations de défense des
droits humains avocat magistrat et
syndicat ont constaté et dénoncé
l'absence récurrente du port de Rio et
cela pour toutes les catégories
confondues nous l'avons nous-mêmes
observé sur le terrain dans le cadre des
mobilisations sociales et du maintien de
l'ordre or nous savons que
l'identification de l'agent est
indispensable pour le contrôle de son
action elle permet notamment de lutter
contre les contrôles d'identité
discriminatoire
comme le rappelle le Comité contre la
torture des Nations Unies les États
doivent veiller à ce que tous les
membres des forces de l'ordre portent un
badge d'identification visible afin
d'assurer qu'ils rendent compte de leurs
actes lors des mobilisations récentes on
a remarqué notamment dans une unité
labrav que des agents étaient
entièrement cagoulés avec le rio
totalement absent alors qu'il n'y avait
aucun danger imminent ce qui est
contraire au schéma national de maintien
de l'ordre depuis 2014 le port du Rio
est obligatoire mais il n'y a pas de
sanction automatique Dans votre rapport
vous indiquez avoir rencontré une
trentaine d'associations mais aussi les
principaux acteurs britanniques en
matière de déontologie policière et vous
avez notamment échangé sur la
traçabilité des contrôles d'identité et
les dimensions discriminatoires de
certains contrôles est-ce que vous
pourrez nous indiquer ce qui en est
ressorti et auriez-vous des
recommandations concrètes pour rendre
effectif à la fois l'obligation du port
du Rio mais aussi pour le rendre visible
de toutes et tous dans le cadre
d'opérations de maintien de l'ordre
merci Monsieur Jean Tellier
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Défenseur des droits merci pour votre
présence aujourd'hui à cette audition
ainsi que la qualité de votre rapport
une fois n'est pas coutume je vous
poserai une question relative au droit
des droits des enfants vous avez évoqué
dans le cadre de votre rapport un
certain nombre de problématiques liés
notamment à la prise en charge des
mineurs dans le cadre de l'aide sociale
à l'enfance mais aussi également des
mineurs non accompagnés sauf erreur de
lecture de ma part il n'y a pas dans
votre rapport de problématique en lien
avec la délinquance des mineurs on vous
avait auditionné dans le cadre de notre
mission d'information avec Cécile
wintermeyer sur ce sujet alors ma
première question c'était de savoir si
le Défenseur des droits que vous êtes a
été saisi dans le cadre de l'application
du CGPM d'un certain nombre de
difficultés et je voulais aussi
également vous dire que vous l'avez
rappelé vous êtes l'observatoire de ce
qui ne va pas mais dans le cas de
fonctions défenseur des droit un certain
nombre d'avis votre prédécesseur l'avait
fait notamment en 2019 lorsqu'il
s'agissait de mettre en application et
de voter ce CJPM en apportant un certain
nombre de comment dirais-je de
réticence si je puis dire sur un certain
nombre de problématiques notamment sur
l'âge de la responsabilité pénale du
mineur sur le mécanisme de la de la
césure pénale sur la question de
l'audience unique mais aussi sur la
question de la détention provisoire des
moyens des binaires pardon et aussi
également des moyens mis en place dans
le cadre de cette réforme et je pense
qu'il serait souhaitable même si
effectivement vous êtes cette
observatoire de ce qui ne va pas lorsque
le Défenseur des droits rend un avis et
émet un certain nombre de réticences à
l'endroit d'un certain nombre de mesures
qui sont votées par par les malheurs par
le parlementaires peut-être que vous
faisiez aussi vous rendiez par la suite
pardon un avis sur le fait que vous
considériez que les choses vont plutôt
dans le bon sens ou pas je pense que ça
aidera la représentation nationale et
certains de nos collègues à pouvoir se
positionner sur la pertinence de la mise
en place de telle ou telle mesure madame
betris rouleau
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Défenseur des droits je voudrais vous
interroger sur les thématiques numéro 2
et numéro 4 des 7 qui font l'objet de
votre rapport laissez-moi vous dire que
j'ai été assez choquée parce que j'ai pu
lire au paragraphe 2 vous constatez que
les occupants sentent bénéficient du
droit au respect de la vie privée
familiale ou à
l'inviobiolabilité de leur domicile et
en conséquence vous condamnez fermement
la proposition de loi relative à la
lutte contre l'occupation illicite qui
pour vous entraîne des restrictions
inquiétantes des droits fondamentaux des
occupants
mais madame la Défenseur des droits que
faites-vous des droits fondamentaux des
propriétaires faut-il renoncer à les
protéger et à légiférer pour s'occuper
pour s'opposer à l'occupation illicite
pensez-vous que les droits fondamentaux
des propriétaires ne doivent pas eux
aussi être protégés il n'y a aucune
raison à ce que les propriétaires ne
puissent pas exercer leurs droits
fondamentaux comme leur respect à leur
vie privée l'un violabilité de leur
domicile et leur droit de propriété
et entre deux titulaires de droits
fondamentaux à protéger ne pensez-vous
pas qu'il faille préférer ceux qui sont
dans l'égalité plutôt que ceux qui sont
dans l'illégalité
c'est en tout cas ce que pense la
majorité des français et en particulier
les propriétaires victimes d'occupation
illégale parfois organisée par des
filières qui qui eux se retrouvent
contraint de dormir dans la rue ou dans
leur voiture
le droit au logement opposable c'est à
l'État à le prendre en charge pas aux
propriétaires privés
sur le quatrième point en revanche au
sujet de l'accompagnement humain des
élèves en situation de handicap nous ne
pouvons que vous rejoindre il manque des
aesh chaque visite en circonscription en
témoigne les raisons
attendez monsieur
pour notre réflexion parlementaire mais
aussi nos propositions c'est d'ailleurs
à partir de notamment de deux de vos
travaux sur la question de la
dématérialisation et à l'Inter suite à
l'interpellation de d'associations que
j'ai élaboré une proposition de loi sur
le sujet je vois que c'est quand même un
sujet qui transversal puisqu'on est tous
et toutes souvent sollicités sur ces
questions et j'espère qu'on va pouvoir
avancer sur ce sujet pour maintenir des
accès physique des accès d'accueil
physique pour les usagers les usagers en
matière de service public
plus que ce n'est fait aujourd'hui je
voudrais revenir sur ce point sur un sur
une question en particulier c'est le
problème la fermeture des accueils
physiques des services de la CNAV parce
que c'est notamment suite à
l'interpellation d'associations dans ma
circonscription qui se retrouvait
submergé par la venue d'usagers
d'usagère des ayants droits en fait qui
ne trouvait porte-close avec auprès de
la CNAV et du coup les associations se
retrouvent à devoir gérer en fait les
procédures pour pour ces personnes sans
être formé sans avoir les moyens etc et
en Île-de-France un certain nombre de
ces associations se sont regroupées au
sein d'un collectif retraite île de IDF
Île-de-France pour faire entendre leur
revendications en disant nous ne sommes
pas les sous-traitants des de l'État et
qu'il faut réouvrir des agences de
proximité ce collectif a notamment
interpellé
l'administration de la CNAV avec des
actions des tribunes des demandes de
rendez-vous mais les réponses qu'elles
ont reçues de cette administration sont
peu conséquents on leur a dit notamment
qu'on va leur faire des emails
spécifiques etc et donc je me demandais
sur ce type de sujet est-ce que votre
institution peut jouer le rôle de
médiation entre des collectifs comme
ceux-là et les administrations pour
permettre en fait une sortie par le haut
des et des résultats concrets sur de tel
sujet merci et bien pour cette deuxième
série de réponses sachant que j'aurai
encore quatre inscrits pour une dernière
série de questions ensuite madame la
Défenseur des droits vous avez la parole
merci
sur la question de quels moyens on fait
pour pour aller aller vers les personnes
et le rôle de nos délégués territoriaux
alors d'abord il y a 2500 français
services on est présent dans 100 on a
570 délégués donc petit rapide calcul on
peut pas être dans tous les espaces
françaises enfin on l'a fait ce calcul
là c'est pas possible nous n'avons pas
les moyens ou alors vous augmentez
fortement nos moyens et on est partant
pour y être dans l'ensemble mais il faut
qu'on soit
le faire il faut qu'on soit 2500 au
moins 2500 délégués pour pouvoir assurer
une présence dans tous les espaces sans
service et c'est assez intéressant ce
qu'on observe alors les espaces
françaises c'est mieux avec que 100 mais
manifestement c'est pas complètement la
panacée ils arrivent à résoudre un
certain nombre de difficultés basiques
mais dès qu'il faut accéder en fait au
dossier et là il faut un agent ou de la
CAF ou de la CPAM ou de la CNAV
justement pour pouvoir accéder au
dossier et ça les agents francs service
ne peuvent pas et donc nous depuis le
début on préconisé que dans ces espaces
en service y est justement des agents
des différents services publics pour
pouvoir accéder au dossier ou alors
faut-il réfléchir à ce que ces agents
dans les espaces françaises et aussi
accès à différents dossiers mais ça veut
dire qu'il faut qu'ils aient une sacrée
formation je dirais pour être bilingue
en CAF et en CPAM et en toutes ces
questions là où trilingue parce que
c'est quand même c'est quand même assez
compliqué mais donc c'est une première
réponse intéressante mais pour nous ça
ne va pas encore suffisamment loin et
quand on entend certains services
publics qui ferment leur accueil sous
prétexte qui a des espaces françaises on
dit que ça c'est absolument délétère et
ça enfin à propos de la queue à
l'accueil physique est juste et juste
indispensable et donc nos délégués
territoriaux vraiment ce qui constate
dans on est en train de faire une
remontée de ce qu'ils observent dans les
espaces en service donc je pourrais vous
en dire plus après mais globalement dans
les échanges que j'ai avec eux et moi
quand j'ai vu aussi des espaces en
service en fait ça fonctionne bien quand
les services publics en question ne sont
pas trop en souffrance c'est-à-dire
arrive à traiter l'ensemble des dossiers
dans ces cas là il y a une forme de
fluidité et d'échange si par exemple je
pense à un endroit à Marseille où la CAF
était en très grande difficulté parce
que manque d'agent trop de dossiers ils
arrivaient pas à traiter en fait ça se
répercute aussi sur les Francs services
qui du coup n'ont pas de réponse quand
ils appellent les les CAF les cafs en
question voilà je sais pas si ça répond
en partie à votre question sur ma prime
rénov moi ce qui m'impressionne sur ma
prime rénov c'est que les difficultés
persistent enfin et quand on nous dit
enfin la réponse honnêtement la réponse
de Lana a été un petit peu mais vous
avez pas eu beaucoup de réclamation en
gros mais si on en a si peu pourquoi
elles sont pas réglées pourquoi on
répond toujours pas à nos délégués et
puis en fait ce qu'on a vu on a bien vu
qu'il y avait un avocat qui s'était un
pari d'un certain nombre de dossiers non
nous voilà la situation des personnel
même nous inquiète la situation des
mandataires c'est-à-dire on a plusieurs
petites entreprises qui boivent le
bouillon en ce moment parce qu'ils n'ont
pas eu les ils ont avancé ils n'ont pas
eu les aides qu'il fallait et du coup du
coup ça ne ça ne fonctionne pas donc non
nous on trouve que
le problème n'est pas suffisamment
réglé il y a encore de graves
difficultés et encore sur tout ce que je
vous disais des non-réponses quand on
quand on les quand on les sollicite vous
me posiez aussi une question sur le
schéma de maintien de l'ordre et ça me
permettra d'aborder en même temps le
port du port du Rio le schéma de
maintien de l'ordre on avait fait donc
une première décision c'était mon
prédécesseur en 2018 de façon générale
au moment de de l'élaboration du schéma
de maintien de l'ordre j'avais rendu
aussi un avis dont on soulignait les
avancées la volonté de mieux communiquer
le port du Rio obligatoire
l'interdiction des cagoules on se
désolait du fait que il y avait pas
aussi l'interdiction des des LBD et des
grenades de désencerclement pourquoi
nous disons ça parce que nous avons
observé dans de nombreuses
manifestations des accidents dus à cet
usage et que nous sommes un des seuls
pays européens à continuer à utiliser
ces LBD et ses grenades des
encerclements en manifestation et notre
préconisation c'est que dans ce là elle
doit pas elles doivent pas être
utilisées d'ailleurs dans les dernières
manifestations elles ont été très
rarement utilisées on a vu vraiment la
baisse de façon absolument
considérable sur la question pour
continuer justement sur le sur le
maintien de l'or sur le port du sur le
port du Rio oui alors en fait que nous
observons pour l'instant mais je vous
dis on est au début de nos enquêtes moi
j'ai pas envie de me prononcer trop sur
l'ensemble des réclamations qu'on a mais
effectivement je suis comme vous j'ai vu
quelques images ce qui nous ennuie c'est
que ce schéma de maintien de l'ordre il
est pas complètement appliqué on voit
encore effectivement des forces de
l'ordre sans port du Rio et évidemment
c'est pas ça qui va rétablir la
confiance nous quand on est saisi de
situation où le port du Rio est
invisible on a du mal à savoir de qui et
de qui il s'agit alors souvent les
forces de sécurité des forces de
sécurité disent mais nous on est en
capacité de le dire c'est vrai il y a
certains moments ils en sont capables
pas toujours enfin on a eu quand même
moi c'était mon étonnement quand je suis
arrivé une des premières décisions qu'on
a rendu sur le fait de de au moment des
manifestations leur travail un jeune
homme au sol donc il est maîtrisé à ce
moment-là sur lequel un policier
continuait à donner des coups la
question de la nécessité de la
proportionnalité puisque les forces de
l'ordre on l'usage de la force de
l'ennemi absolument pas mais de façon
nécessaire et proportionnée quand le
jeune homme est à terre et maîtrisé la
l'usage de la force n'est ni nécessaire
ni proportionnelle il était cagoulé
personne n'a été capable de nous dire
qui c'était ni les policiers autour ni
l'encadrement et nous n'avons plus que
constater que nous ne pouvions juste
dire qu'il aurait dû y avoir une
sanction disciplinaire et que nous
pouvions rien faire et on peut toujours
être étonné d'ailleurs que l'encadrement
ne soit pas en capacité de le dire du
coup vous élargissiez votre pardon
si si aucun doute aucun doute aucun
doute il parlait avec les autres
policiers on n'a pas de doute là-dessus
il est la question vous élargissez votre
question là sur le port du Rio aux
questions de contrôle d'identité ou
effectivement je suis allé voir et je
fais ça régulièrement nos homologues et
entre autres l'Ayo piscine à Londres où
ça me permet de dire entre parenthèses
qu'ils sont 1000 quand nous nous avons
12 juristes pour la le contrôle la
déontologie des forces de sécurité et en
Grande-Bretagne et ben il y a pas de
contrôle d'identité vous savez pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont pas de pièce d'identité
et évidemment il y a des contrôles c'est
pas une zone de non-droit et sans
contrôle donc il y a des contrôles ils
appellent ça les stopsurf ils arrêtent
des personnes ils peuvent vous demander
vous poser un certain nombre de
questions et faire aussi une fouille et
pendant que nous nous ne savons pas si
nous avons 5 8 ou 12 millions de
contrôles d'identité en France ils ont
780 000 pour l'année 2021 stop and
search d'habitude ils sont plutôt autour
de 550 000 puisqu'il y a une traçabilité
et la traçabilité c'est tout simplement
que c'est enregistré sur une tablette au
moment où la personne est contrôlée et
la personne qui est contrôlée qui peut
considérer qu'elle a été victime
justement de discrimination ou contester
peut le lendemain aller au commissariat
et obtenir un récipissé en France nous
ne savons pas donc je l'ai dit si nous
avons 5 8 ou 12 millions de contrôles
d'identité j'ai saisi la Cour des
comptes pour faire une évaluation de ce
nombre de contrôle d'identité de leurs
résultats quelques résultats ça en terme
de détection et puis quel impact sur la
relation police population la Cour des
comptes m'a déjà auditionné m'a déjà dit
que la première question elle ne pouvait
pas y répondre puisqu'il y a pas de
traçabilité donc ça on se doutait que
vous allez pas répondre aux 5 8 ou 12
millions de contre l'identité mais c'est
quand même assez incroyable parce que
comme en terme de dépenses publiques
aussi et de sens pour les pour les
forces de l'ordre les forces de l'ordre
nous interpellent aussi là-dessus sur le
fait qu'elles en ont un peu assez de
faire des faire des contrôles identités
donc je redis que la question
essentielle et la question de la
traçabilité que quand je sens le blocage
à ce point là je pense qu'il faut mener
des expérimentations qui comparent les
phénomènes de traçabilité donc il y a la
Cour des comptes devrait rendre son
rapport je crois d'ici la fin de l'année
j'ai les associations en saisie le
Conseil d'État le Conseil d'État nous a
demandé de faire des observations
formation ce que nous avons fait nous
avons aussi fait des observations devant
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
donc on vous tiendra bien évidemment au
courant
sur
les services publics et l'alternative et
qu'est-ce qu'on propose comme solution
d'abord merci beaucoup pour vos propos
sur l'institution et je vous remercie
tous ceux qui sont intervenus sur vos
propos sur l'institution institution
dont je le rappelle est-ce que dans la
Constitution vous l'avez dit et ça
montre votre respect de la Constitution
je vous en remercie la question de
l'accès aux services publics et de
l'accès de l'accès au guichet non en
fait la dématérialisation je continue à
dire que c'est une chose enfin pour
plein de personnes ça permet de faire
ces démarches à n'importe quel moment du
jour et de la nuit donc la question
c'est vous l'avez dit vous-même en fait
j'ai rien de plus à rajouter c'est le
guichet c'est en fait pouvoir aller voir
quelqu'un quand ça ne fonctionne pas le
guichet et le téléphone mais le
téléphone on est sur la même question
que les Français services il faut au
bout du fil quelqu'un qui accès à votre
dossier parce que si c'est quelqu'un
pour juste vous donner quelques
recommandations générales dans le
testing qu'on avait fait qui était assez
puissant avec la situation de la
consommation c'est que quand bien même
au téléphone les gens disaient je n'ai
pas internet le conseil qu'il aurait été
donné au téléphone c'était d'aller sur
le site internet et d'aller voir et pour
savoir quelles étaient les démarches à
faire et puis on avait aussi observé des
erreurs dans les informations qui
étaient données donc en fait à chaque
fois la question et c'est qui a accès au
dossier et à mon avis le la question est
essentiellement là-dessus vous avez
aussi vous nous avez aussi posé des
questions sur sur le l'homophobie la
discrimination est-ce que nos ce que
nous pouvons observer d'abord vous
rappeler que nous sommes en charge de la
lutte contre les discriminations et donc
ça veut dire que les violences
homophobes ne rentrent pas dans nos
compétences donc ça c'est important et
de rappeler mais c'est toujours assez
complexe de rappeler la loi et pas
toujours voilà pas toujours très facile
que de rappeler ce qu'est une
discrimination c'est une différence de
traitement dans un des domaines prévues
par la loi l'emploi l'accès aux services
et dans un des critères et dont il y a
effectivement la question de
l'orientation de l'orientation sexuelle
je vous dire du coup parce que vous
grandit un peu aussi vous qu'est-ce
qu'on observe dans les discriminations
si je vous cite quelques quelques
situations récentes d'abord des
questions de harcèlement d'enfants à
l'école liés à l'orientation scolaire et
de évidemment alors quand ça arrive chez
nous c'est que ça pas été bien prise en
charge par l'école dans de nombreux cas
c'est bien prise en charge pas l'école
et nous quand ça nous arrive c'est qu'il
y a eu un problème et que ça a été mal
pris en charge et donc de retard
d'écoute de de l'enfant du mineur et et
retard de prise en charge des questions
on a vu des reflux d'enregistrer des
plaintes je pense à un couple de femmes
lesbiennes qui étaient une femme victime
de violence qui a voulu porter plainte
au commissariats refusent des potes
plaintes nous sommes aussi compétents
sur ces questions là et c'est d'ailleurs
nos déléguer dans ces cas-là qui appelle
le commissariat en disant vous devez
vous devez prendre la plainte et en
général d'ailleurs ça se règle ça se
règle assez vite mais c'est quand même
très délétère comme comme premier comme
premier contact on a eu aussi une
situation de manière qui a refusé de
marier un couple un couple homosexuel
donc oui on voit des situations comme
celle-là de discrimination puis vous
faire part de la dernière sur lequel
nous rendrons très probablement
par rapport spécial avec une publication
au Journal officiel d'un couple
homosexuel qui travaille dans la grande
distribution et qui le jour où le son
employeur découvre qu'ils sont en couple
les mets sur des horaires totalement
différents incompatibles avec la vie
privée et sur lequel il y a eu aucune
compensation c'est-à-dire on est
vraiment enfin vous disiez qu'est-ce
qu'on fait quand on arrive pas de la
médiation quand nos décisions sont pas
suivies des faits et bien là c'est
probablement ce que nous allons faire
dans les dans les dans les prochains
dans les prochains jours nous
participons tout le travail sur le plan
le prochain plan d'Élisabeth d'Isabelle
Rome sur la lutte contre contre
l'homophobie comme dans l'avion fait sur
la question de la lutte contre la
discrimination origine le plan contre de
lutte contre le racisme l'antisémitisme
et les discriminations et nous essayons
effectivement de voilà de dire à la fois
ce que nous observons et ce qui est ce
qu'il faudrait faire on est plutôt en
dialogue en toute intelligence très
franchement alors sur le plan sur de le
premier plan qui était sur le racisme
antisémitisme et la lutte contre les
discriminations il y a des annonces qui
sont intéressantes nous allons
maintenant être vigilants sur le suivi
de ce qui sera vraiment de ce qui sera
vraiment fait
et vous vous soulignez aussi le fait
qu'il faut informer communiquer sur ces
sur ces discriminations vous avez
parfaitement raison et c'est une des
choses où là on n'a pas on n'a jamais
récupéré les moyens qui avaient la halle
en communication et je pense que c'est
indispensable de communiquer sur les
discriminations sur veluter efficacement
contre et ceci dit nous on veut bien que
ce soit le gouvernement qui fasse des
grandes campagnes de communication sur
les discriminations mais il y a un vrai
besoin de le faire et de le faire et de
le faire très très largement sur la
question des des que vous m'avez posé
sur les droits des étrangers
le
l'immense majorité des réclamations que
nous recevons sont vraiment pour des
renouvellements de titre de séjour de
personnes qui les qui les auraient quoi
qu'il arrive et donc l'embolisation de
l'institution n'est absolument pas dû à
ce que vous citez de personnes qui sont
en situation
irrégulière quand bien même nous
traitons aussi d'ailleurs leur
réclamation mais l'immense majorité sont
des personnes qui sont parfaitement en
situation régulière qui se retrouvent
comme vous l'avez dit en situation
irrégulière avec des délais de
traitement vous me demandez quels sont
les quels sont nos préconisations alors
nos préconisations restent rejoignent
d'ailleurs ce qu'a dit le Conseil d'État
c'est qu'il faut pouvoir avoir déposé un
dossier papier et un accueil physique
après la deuxième préconisation je suis
pas sûr qu'elle vous plaise mais je
pense que c'est une des seules moyens de
désengorger les préfectures ces carrêter
de faire des des autorisations de ces
jours d'un an vous les faites de deux
ans et vous désengorger de fait les
préfectures sur des personnes qui auront
des renouvellements de cartes de séjour
et je pense que c'est absolument
essentiel et je pense qu'il y a urgence
là à arrêter de créer des situations qui
appauvrissent les personnes enfin je
veux dire on est on nous on a des
réclamants qui se retrouvent qui perdent
leur emploi et qui se retrouvent expulsé
de leur logement alors qu'ils
obtiendront après on a des mamans avec
des enfants qui se retrouvent dans des
situations une femme de 82 ans ça fait
50 ans qu'elle est en France elle aura
le renouvellement de sa carte de séjour
elle se retrouve en situation
irrégulière son fils est en train de
décéder en Algérie elle peut pas lire le
voir elle peut pas aller à l'enterrement
parce que elle a pas pu déposer sa
demande elle a pas pu avoir de
rendez-vous je pense qu'on crée des
situations qui pour moi sont absolument
sont absolument inadmissibles
comme et donc dans mes améliorations sur
sur la question la préfecture ça ça
reste ça reste nos préconisations sur le
contrôle et l'application de la loi loop
me alors oui je je sais pas où en est le
Parlement concrètement sur le travail
qui lui avait été confié de contrôle
nous ne sommes pas associés nous voulons
bien être associés
je sais pas si vous avez quelque chose
qui suit le l'application de la loi mais
surtout on a un comité de suivi c'est à
dire que tous les trois mois on est reçu
une seule intérieur avec tous les chefs
de service du ministère intérieur pour
poser les questions qui sont celles
qu'on a posé sur l'application des
différentes dispositions avec ensuite
des démonstrations et et toute une série
d'échanges qui sont assez libres pour
que l'on puisse contrôler la mise en
oeuvre donc c'est peut-être dans ce
cadre là que
vous pourriez interagir avec tous les
directeurs d'administration centrale
en tout cas vous nous tenez au courant
effectivement
sur les les droits des les droits des
enfants la vie qu'on a pu rendu et le
suivi qu'on peut faire de nos avis vous
avez parfaitement raison on fait un
suivi en fait en général de nos
recommandations on est plutôt dans une
phase où c'est encore un peu trop tôt
quand même ça peut vous paraître déjà
trois ans mais on vous l'avez déjà dit
on vous l'avez déjà dit à l'époque mais
on suit effectivement de près et nous
faisons des suivis de nos avis on
continue à faire le chiffre c'est
d'avoir le chiffre du nombre d'avis
qu'on a rendu en 2022 je sais pas si
quelqu'un l'a combien cet avis au
Parlement donc on continue très
fortement à rendre des avis à faire des
suivis de nos avis donc ça c'est c'est
vous avez tout à fait raison et on
continuera et on vous dira où on en est
sur la loi sur l'occupation sur
l'occupation illicite
notre vous vous soulignez effectivement
une confrontation finalement entre deux
droits le droit à la propriété le droit
au maintien de la vie privée
effectivement c'est une confrontation de
deux droits cette loi nous paraît très
inquiétante d'abord parce que les
situations de squat sont exceptionnelles
je ne dis pas qu'elle n'existe pas mais
elles sont exceptionnelles il faut les
régler et je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y ait
besoin d'une nouvelle loi pour ça mais
pas mais il faut les régler je n'ai pas
de doute mais c'est exceptionnel et
faire une loi pour que quelques cas ne
me paraît pas raisonnable en revanche ça
va précariser un certain nombre de
personnes qui sont déjà ça vous a pas
échappé qu'il y a quand même une partie
de la population en grande difficulté
avec l'augmentation des prix de
l'alimentaire en difficulté pour payer
leur loyer on va précariser ces
personnes là qui n'auront plus accès au
juge et excusez-moi je continue à penser
que l'administration doit être contrôlé
par l'autorité judiciaire ça me paraît
indispensable là on éloigne le juge on
le fait de façon assez régulière en ce
moment sous un prétexte d'efficacité et
ça m'inquiète donc oui effectivement
nous avons deux positions différentes
nous avons la confrontation de deux
droits un droit à la propriété et un
droit à la vie privée et nous avons nous
mis en avant la question de la
protection du droit à la vie privée qui
nous paraissait important je suis très
inquiète des conséquences qu'on va avoir
cette loi en termes d'expulsion de
personnes qui sont en grande difficulté
les expulsions que nous observons déjà
sont excessivement inquiétantes sur le
manque d'aesh comme quoi vous voyez
qu'il y a certains de nos positions qui
vous qui vous conviennent et c'est assez
normal que nos positions ne conviennent
pas à l'ensemble des personnes je n'ai
pas de souci là-dessus j'entends bien la
question pourquoi la gratter s'il vous
plaît je redis ce que nous avons dit sur
la question de l'inclusion scolaire des
enfants en situation de handicap
l'accompagnement des aesh n'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga je veux dire
l'inclusion scolaire passe aussi par la
question de la formation des enseignants
la question de classe en peu plus petits
effectifs et et la question de du
programme scolaire de toutes ces
questions là c'est pas simplement les
aesh et oui il faut absolument mieux
rémunérer les aesh simplement plein
temps enfin je veux dire parce qu'en
fait elles sont toutes sur 24 heures
évidemment je dis toutes vous voyez bien
que des femmes parce que du coup que des
femmes sur la question des
matérialisation et et et la cnaville de
France oui nous observons exactement les
mêmes choses que vous moi je suis très
inquiète on a des réclamants qui qui
c'est un peu la même chose que ce que je
vous avais dit sur sur la Guadeloupe et
Martinique on a des réclamants qui ont
fait valoir leurs droits à la retraite
et pas six mois un an 18 mois 2 ans sans
pension mais sans rien on a la j'étais
encore interpellé par nos délégués
territoriaux des pensions de réversion
qui ne sont pas versées des pièces des
demandes de pièces supplémentaires alors
que les pièces ont déjà été versées au
dossier alors là pareil pas de critique
sur les agents en l'occurrence de ces
services publics qui eux-mêmes sont en
difficulté mais on est enfin je trouve
ça excessivement inquiétant et
l'intégralité de la dématérialisation
aussi des démarches qui fait qu'on peut
avoir personne savoir où en est mon
dossier qu'est-ce qui se passe on
comprend aussi pourquoi ça coince
c'est-à-dire ça et ça ça reste la
difficulté oui on peut tout à fait
échanger avec des collectifs on n'est
pas toujours enfin ça veut pas forcément
dire être saisi mais on peut échanger et
on échange d'ailleurs déjà avec des
collectifs sur sur ces questions
je crois que j'ai répondu à l'ensemble
donc la parole
bonjour Merci beaucoup madame de votre
venue
ma question qui nous permet de nous
éclairer d'une façon objective sur la
situation dans le pays sur l'accès aux
droits ma question est la suivante donc
au mois d'avril 2022 a été examinée et
voté à l'Assemblée nationale la loi dite
Jo et autres dispositions au sein de
celle-ci une proposition
d'expérimentation de la vidéo
surveillance algorithmique
a été votée et ce à des fins que nous
jugeons tout à fait discutables de
sécurité de surcroît il est remarquable
de constater que cette expérimentation
va au-delà et en de ça d'ailleurs de la
durée des Jeux Olympiques eux-mêmes
liberté d'aller venir droit à la vie
privée expression Pacifique d'une
opinion nous paraissent menacée de
surcroît nous le savons ce qui
caractérise aussi ses affaires de vidéo
surveillance qui s'appuie sur des
algorithmes c'est la question des biais
d'ailleurs j'ai lu et j'ai trouvé que
c'était tout à fait pertinent que ces
affaires là au fond étaient une bonne
façon de pratiquer une introspection
relativement à nos à nos préjugés bref
au-delà donc de la multiplication et de
l'élargissement massif des usages de
l'intelligence artificielle et ce en
dehors de tout cadre sérieux de
réflexion pourtant nous y avons mis
toute notre énergie afin de susciter des
débats des arguments des
contre-arguments relativement à ces
dispositifs mais ce vraisemblablement en
vain lors de de l'examen de ce projet de
loi
non seulement en dehors de tout cadre de
mais aussi en dehors de tout cadre
éthique nous nous interrogeons donc même
si nous savons que vous êtes exprimé sur
le sujet mais ça nous paraît important
que vous puissiez dans le cadre de cette
commission des lois dont le respect des
libertés fondamentales et une pierre
angulaire que vous puissiez vous
réexprimer à nouveau sur ce sujet de
l'intelligence artificielle je vous
remercie
Président Madame le Défenseur des droits
vous déplorez dans votre rapport qu'en
matière d'accompagnement financier des
lanceurs d'alerte le législateur est
préférait à la création d'un fond de
soutien dédié un dispositif de soutien
financier psychologique à la charge des
autorités externes dans votre avis du 29
octobre 2021 vous indiquez que ce fond
aurait été financé par les amendes
prononcées en cas de manquement à
l'obligation de mettre en place des
procédures de signalement outre le fait
que cette source de financement semble
peut-être trop fragile pour financer le
dispositif je m'interroge sur le
caractère déontologique d'un tel fond de
soutien si le lanceur d'alerte peut
bénéficier d'une rétribution comment
prouver son désintéressement dans
l'affaire qu'il rapporte d'autant plus
que vous avez encouragé la suppression
de la condition de désintéressement pour
les personnes qui souhaiteraient
bénéficier de protection d'autre part
vous constatez des limites sur les
champs d'application des dispositifs de
protection des lanceurs d'alerte outre
la question du signalement pour un cas
personnel quels sont selon vous les
limites de la certification je vous
remercie
merci Madame sors Gol
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
la défenseur des droits de nous rappeler
combien la logique qui fond dans notre
pays à savoir celle de se reposer compte
sur des contre-pouvoirs d'avoir des
poils à gratter comme disait mon
collègue et que et d'avoir des personnes
en capacité de d'apporter cette critique
qui est de rappeler ce qui ne va pas
pour qu'on arrive à avancer ensemble à
l'améliorer c'est vraiment précieux et
je pense que vous aurez pu voir que
parfois dans notre institution qui est
pourtant et celle qui représente le
peuple il n'est pas toujours évident de
rappeler que la critique est un outil
pour travailler pour s'améliorer et pour
éclairer le choix des législateurs donc
merci encore une fois vous avez déjà
répondu partiellement à beaucoup de mes
interrogations
mais il reste un sujet qu'on vient
d'aborder celui des lanceurs d'alerte
qui reste vous le dites on vous a
beaucoup reproché de ne faire que de la
critique dans votre rapport vous
préciser que c'est une avancée que
d'avoir ça c'est pas le seul sujet mais
il faut peut-être avoir une lecture plus
attentive pour voir que la critique
n'est pas votre seul outil pour faire
avancer nos droits collectifs bref nous
avons beaucoup parlé de la police et des
lanceurs d'alerte et j'aimerais faire un
lien entre les deux oui il y a des
questions qui se posent en interne des
agents des forces de l'ordre qu'il
s'agissent de la police ou de la
gendarmerie et vous recueillez une
partie de leurs interrogations le statut
de lanceur d'alerte il est encore
balbutien il est en train d'être mis en
place et votre rapport rappelle que on
est à la croisée des chemins pour
pouvoir avancer quand on est à
l'intérieur d'une institution par
particulièrement quand on est à
l'intérieur d'une institution qui doit
appliquer le droit dans son équité n'est
pas toujours facile de pouvoir
solliciter ce stat ut qui est pourtant
essentiel pour faire avancer une
institution qui on le voit bien en
comparaison internationale et vous
l'avez dit vous-même n'est pas toujours
mieux donc comment utiliser au mieux ce
statut pour aider nos agents apporter au
mieux le droit en égalité sur le
territoire monsieur Hugo bernalicis
merci monsieur le Président déjà vous
remercier pour inciter le rapport que
j'ai commis sur une station générale les
territoriales de l'État sur l'accès au
service public ceci étant dit Madame la
Défenseur des droits
j'ai commencé par vous poser la question
que je vous ai posé la dernière fois
pour faire un petit point sur les moyens
vous les avez évoqué donc j'aimerais
qu'on fasse un petit point sur les
moyens j'ai vu dans le dans le budget
2023 que vous aviez généreusement deux
ETPT en plus
voilà regarde ce que vous avez pu nous
dire sur ne serait-ce que uniquement la
déontologie de la sécurité les moyens
qu'on nos voisins anglais voilà vous en
êtes quels sont les les besoins qui sont
les vôtres dans les différents domaines
ça me semble important de rappeler on
est en plein dans le printemps de
l'évaluation à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est une abuse en matière budgétaire
donc c'est le bon moment pour cela je
vais utiliser le fin du temps qui me
reste pour vous questionner sur la
déontologie de la sécurité et notamment
un certain nombre d'aspects qui ils ont
inquiété nous aussi à savoir les arrêter
d'interdiction qui ont été pris par les
préfectures dans des délais qui ne
permettent pas la contestation devant
les tribunaux administratifs dans des
bonnes conditions même si des militants
des professeurs de droits des avocats
ont réussi à déployer des ressources
extraordinaires pour déposer des délais
des recours en moins d'une heure à
certains moments mais enfin la
démocratie ne peut pas reposer sur des
militants qui s'acharnent en moins d'une
heure à déposer des recours me
semble-t-il et je m'inquiète aussi de
voir que la conséquence de ça c'est que
il continue d'y avoir des arrêtés pris
dans des délais qui empêchent la
contestation comment on peut faire
évoluer les choses et puis je terminerai
en vous demandant un petit retour
d'expérience nous avons appris que vous
étiez au centre de commandement à la
préfecture de police lors d'une des
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites que quand retenez vous qui
avez qu'est-ce que vous y avez vu
comment ça s'est passé merci Madame la
défenseur et enfin Monsieur
merci monsieur le Président alors déjà
je veux vous remercier Madame la
Défenseur des droits d'être présente ici
je crois que c'est plus conforme au rôle
de notre commission d'étudier le
maintien des droits que de d'étudier la
présence de drapeaux sur le fronton des
mairies ou de portraits de Monsieur
Macron d'ailleurs dedans
je j'aimerais vous interroger sur les
les arrestations arbitraires parce que
vous avez alerté sur le sujet madame
Simoneau également alerté sur le sujet
j'aimerais vous questionner sur le lien
avec la Déclaration des Droits de
l'Homme et du Citoyen puisque cette
déclaration de dictation d'article 7 que
nul homme ne peut être accusé arrêté ni
détenu que dans les cas déterminés par
la Loi et selon les formes qu'elle a
prescrites puisque son article 5 nous
dit que la loi a le droit de défendre
que les actions nuisibles à la société
et que tout ce qui n'est pas défendu par
la loi et jusqu'à preuve du contraire la
manifestation n'est pas défendue par la
loi et elle est même garantie par
l'article 11 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen ne peut
être empêché et nul ne peut être
contraint à faire ce qu'elle n'ordonne
pas et enfin
un article 9 nous dit que tout homme est
en présumé innocent jusqu'à ce qu'il ait
été déclaré coupable si les jugé
indispensable de l'arrêter toute rigueur
qui ne serait pas nécessaire pour
s'assurer de sa personne doit être
sévèrement réprimée par la loi les
arrestations arbitraires sont également
proscrites par l'article 68 de notre
Constitution qui dit que nul ne peut
être arbitrairement détenu et j'aimerais
savoir si vous estimez que dans le cadre
des manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites nous avons fait avec un
certain nombre de mes collègues le tour
des commissariats nous y avons rencontré
beaucoup de jeunes qui étaient arrêtés
beaucoup de jeunes qui ont été relâchés
sans poursuite beaucoup de jeunes qui
ont été poursuivis mes disculpés pour
relaxer de des charges qui étaient qui
étaient prévues contre eux et j'aimerais
savoir enfin si vous estimez du coup que
c'est pratique sont conformes à
l'article 12 de la déclaration du droit
de l'homme et du citoyen la garantie des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen
nécessite une force publique cette force
est donc instituée pour l'avantage de
tous non pour l'utilité particulière de
ceux auquel elle est confiée
merci et donc vos réponses sur cette
dernière série de questions à ma défense
et du coup je fais en fait commencer par
la vôtre parce qu'il y a une des vôtres
auquel j'avais pas répondu sur le nombre
de saisines si si donc je et sur ce que
deviennent effectivement sur les sur
comment voilà comment comment on
intervien donc effectivement je vous
l'ai dit 80 % est un médiation et après
nous rendons un certain nombre de
décisions dans les décisions les plus
importantes c'est passe devant des
collèges en droit des enfants
discrimination et déontologie des forces
de sécurité où il y a des personnalité
qui sont nommées entre autres par la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale le
président du Sénat la Cour de cassation
et le et le Conseil des et le Conseil
d'État donc nous rendons dans ces cas-là
quand la médiation n'est pas possible ou
quand la situation est particulièrement
grave des des décisions pour vous donner
les chiffres en 2021 c'était 298
décisions dont 175 étaient des
observations devant les tribunaux ce
sont aussi des décisions donc ils sont
menés ces décisions sont menées en
enquête en contradictoire et donc
effectivement prennent du temps et c'est
ce qui va se passer donc il y a une
partie des questions que vous m'avez
posé sur les les manifestations sur la
retraite sur lesquelles je ne peux pas
vous répondre pour l'instant parce qu'on
est parti dans le contradictoire et
qu'en plus à certains moments la justice
est saisie donc il nous faut
l'autorisation du procureur pour pouvoir
enquêter donc tout ça va prendre du
temps mais mais nous ferons et sans
aucun doute qu'on appelle ou une
décision cadre des décisions d'abord
individuel à une décisioncade sur ce que
nous avons observé qu'est-ce que ça dit
comme comme atteinte comme atteinte au
droit donc je vous ai dit donc 2021
c'est 298 280 221 décisions en 2022 dont
110 observation et si je prends l'année
2023 on en est déjà 56 décisions sur les
quatre premiers mois et dont 38
observations devant devant devant les
tribunaux voilà et c'est vraiment un des
moyens pour nous importants et des
pouvoirs qu'on a qui sont qui sont qui
sont importantes voilà je voulais
répondre d'abord à votre question ce que
j'ai compris que vous étiez obligé de
partir c'est ça le sur les les les
Jeux Olympiques
sur les jeux sur les Jeux Olympiques et
sur la loi la sur les questions
d'intelligence artificielle nous allons
suivre tout ça très près oui
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
peut qui nous inquiète en tout cas qui
demande surveillance j'ai échangé cette
début de semaine ou c'était lundi avec
la directrice de la présidente de la
CNIL avec qui nous échangeons avec qui
nous faisons aussi puisque nous faisons
partie du collège de droit de l'acnil à
qui nous faisons des voilà à chaque fois
nous demande sur un certain nombre de
recommandations et d'avis que nous
pouvons que nous pouvons donner donc oui
absolument c'est à suivre c'est à suivre
de très près sur la question des
lanceurs d'alerte
et du Fonds de soutien alors il s'agit
absolument pas de rémunérer les lanceurs
d'alerte on arrive au contraire après
quand il y a eu des représailles
qu'est-ce que nous observons chez les
lanceurs d'alerte en fait très souvent
ils sont quand même licenciés au bout du
compte et donc ils sont dans une
situation financière excessivement
difficile donc c'est plutôt après
l'alerte il s'agit en aucun cas de de
les rétribuer et ce que nous observons
pour l'instant c'est quand même une très
grande fragilité des lanceurs d'Avers
c'est une situation honnêtement
absolument
épouvantable pour un certain nombre et
un fond de soutien serait juste là pour
les aider dans ce genre de situation
mais à aucun moment il s'agit de de
soutenir de financer les voilà de
rétribuer les les lanceurs les lanceurs
d'alerte on en est au début de nos
certifications donc l'appareil
laissez-nous un tout petit peu de temps
pour voir ce que ce qu'on ce qu'on peut
observer ce qui est sûr c'est que dans
les réclamations qu'on reçoit il y en a
il y en a plus d'un tiers c'est ça pas
loin de la moitié qui sont sur des
demandes de certification mais dans les
réclamations pas toujours des demandes
de certification voilà ça c'est
et une question qui que j'ai compris
sous-entendu est-ce que dans la police
on peut avoir des lanceurs d'alerte bah
oui oui vous je vous le confirme oui
et des discriminations oui bien sûr bien
sûr aussi en échange d'ailleurs avec une
association
flag de policiers sur la lutte contre
l'homophobie la police de façon très
très intéressante ils font partie de nos
comités d'entente qui est aussi une de
nos forces d'échanger avec le monde avec
le monde associatif
nos moyens vous m'avez demandé plus de
précision de nos sur nos moyens en fait
pour 2023 on avait demandé 5 et TP
supplémentaires deux outils de lanceur
d'alerte et 3 au titre de la
densification du réseau on est vraiment
pas gourmand quand on fait ce genre de
vent et en fait il y a que deux emplois
qui ont été retenus et c'est pas
raisonnable par rapport à l'augmentation
de ce qu'on de alors non moi je suis pas
dans ce là-dessus mais effectivement
nous sommes en train de demander
beaucoup plus que la honnêtement quand
on s'est mis à comparer en déontologie
on le SAV mais la comparaison qu'on
vient de faire avec les emboutements on
est excessivement inquiet donc on est en
train de demander vous le verrez
j'espère arriver au Parlement on espère
bien une augmentation massive de nos
moyens à la fois
en emploi en agent mais aussi en moyen
de communication dans dans les demandes
que nous avions fait on avait une
augmentation pour augmenter nos délégués
entre eux parce qu'on a un problème de
nos délégués qui ont des déplacements et
avec le coût l'augmentation du coût du
déplacement il fallait il fallait
pouvoir augmenter et puis du nombre de
délégués dont on a besoin en revanche on
n'avait pas eu la somme qu'on avait
demandé pour une campagne de
communication juste de référencement de
la plateforme anti discriminations en
fait si on demande pas si on finance pas
le la communication sur le référencement
de la plateforme elle ne revient plus au
début quand vous voit quand on fait un
sur un moteur de recherche et donc c'est
absolument indispensable et je vous
redis ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
nous n'avons toujours pareil pour
l'ensemble de l'institution le budget
communication qui avait la halle à
l'époque donc je pense qu'on n'est pas
raisonnable sur les moyens de
communication vous m'avez aussi sur la
question du respect de droit de
manifester la justice elle a joué son
rôle et on laisse la justice jouer son
rôle on est on est c'est quelque chose
aussi qu'on va surveiller qu'on va voir
dans réclamation aussi que que nous
avons vous m'avez posé la question sur
le centre de commandement mais écoutez
je sais pas un événement d'aller dans le
centre de commandant j'y étais avec
Pauline kabyle on a déjà en charge de la
déontologie des forces de sécurité il y
avait aussi Benoît Narbé qui est le chef
du pôle déontologie qui est qui était là
les échanges égyptiens 3h vous vous êtes
restés même encore plus encore plus
longtemps jusque jusqu'au jusqu'au bout
des échanges très intéressants des
explications j'ai pu poser beaucoup de
questions je vais la directrice de
cabinet à côté de moi et j'ai posé des
questions absolument sans sans
discontinuité et puis également
et vous dire qu'en fait nos échanges
avec les forces de l'ordre sont très
très réguliers enfin nous intervenons
dans les formations de gardiens de la
paix j'échange régulièrement avec
évidemment le préfet de police de Paris
j'ai changé avec le DGPN avec avec la
gendarmerie avec l'iggn l'IGPN nos
échanges sont très très réguliers donc
c'est je veux dire c'est pas un
événement de d'échanger et c'est
vraiment important
pour nous
je crois que j'ai répondu à l'ensemble
des questions non ou il y en avait
d'autres auxquels je n'ai pas répondu
non je crois que c'est tout non la
question de nos moyens honnêtement est
une donc vous arrivez juste
c'est pas mal que je redise un mot sur
sur la question de nos moyens parce que
je pense qu'on a en fait un rôle très
pacificateur en rétablissant les
personnes dans leur droit sur les
réclamations qu'on nous reçoit on apaise
les tensions et là la façon dont
l'institution commence à être embolisée
moi j'ai des délégués qui sont en
souffrance tellement ils ont de
personnes et de dossiers parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à régler toutes les
questions j'ai des agents aussi en
souffrance parce que c'est des
situations de personnes je pense que
l'augmentation des moyens on est un
élément de démocratie il suffit pas
qu'on soit inscrit dans la Constitution
il faut nous donner les moyens
je vois que votre conclusion
merci juste vous remercier pour cette
présentation moi je le redis c'est
utile nécessaire et c'est vous êtes un
garant de la démocratie les démocraties
qui fonctionnent ont des contrôles et ça
fait partie du processus démocratique je
crois qu'on a épuisé l'ordre du jour
donc je vais lever la séance et j'aurais
été d'une grande efficacité